guys thank you so much for buying the
trash taste tour tickets we've sold out
in so many venues so much so that we're
actually adding an extra show an extra
show in los angeles on the 23rd of
september the first la show we had sold
out pretty much right away so we wanted
to add an extra day and because it's
going to be our first show of the tour
it's gonna be a little tester show so if
you want to see an early version of the
show then go to trashtaster.com that is
trashtaster.com
so come see us live get your tickets
smash that link below
if i get to hang out with the cool
people i guess i'll smoke crack actually
speaking of smoking cracks
okay
hello hello hello welcome to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
your host for today joey and as always i
am with the lads
we have a special guest sitting next to
me introduce yourself hi guys i am pokey
pokeymane my actual name is iman feel
free to call me any of the above you
guys can also call me pokey
this just like a trick it's like one of
them is the correct one yeah yeah which
one yeah yeah yeah yeah guess which one
it is
like one of them is a highly offensive
and we're just gonna find out afterwards
which one's the derogatory today
i will admit confession right off the
bat okay i like looked up
all of your guys's names so i could make
sure i could pronounce them right i mean
connor
didn't like joey were [ __ ] but i was
like
that's what everyone thinks
and then i watched the video where you
guys are like our names wrong answers
only and he's talking about like granite
and garbage
yeah i was on like the otv cast the
other day and uh i was on there with
toast and scarra and uh apparently like
scarra was the one who was like familiar
with my content he was selling toast no
no it's not gig uk it's gigantic okay
come on come on you got to research
you got to research your guest right and
then immediately afterwards he says i
know his name's grant it's not ghan it's
grant
sorry to call you out like this scarra
wait did you correct him uh i i correct
them before the podcast
it was it wasn't on film it would have
been a funny that would have been a fun
entire podcast
and then at the end when it's posted
people in the comments are like hmm i'm
pretty sure i've seen this
i did the um the pottery stream with
cutie and i did it and it was really fun
and then i was talking to minx and i was
like oh yeah yeah and um because alex
was also there i did a thing and he's
australian and then i think i don't know
why i was like yeah i live in japan and
then she's like yeah but obviously like
from australia right and i was like
what do you mean things thought you were
australian yeah and i'm like you're
irish you should know
you have no excuse
i'm like you have no excuse for not
knowing that i brutally sound one
percent australian i sound nothing
australian i don't i i sound nothing
australian
is that your impression
is that your caller thank you i
appreciate it i wish i had an accent
like you do have an accident yeah you do
have an american accent
no i'm leaving la right now
bye guys it was nice knowing you okay
because i grew up in canada i was born
in morocco my first language is french
oh and so i think when i first moved to
la i had a bit of like a canadian accent
right you lose that it goes right
um but i do find myself sometimes
sounding a little bit la-esque and it's
very scary
i i don't know like that that's that's
my boundary
as soon as someone tells me i start
sounding like like a valley girl i have
to go i have to go back to my room
oh my [ __ ] god like that kind of
bible the issue is you hear those kind
of things so much
and then sometimes you'll say it
ironically because it feels funny and
good to say ironically
then all of a sudden it's not so ironic
bro everyone would say bro ironically
and now everyone says bro it's like
saying boston or like liv or like that's
the internet term that's me and among us
you know what i mean
it is though it is at first i'm like
this is like cringe as [ __ ] among us why
would people laugh at among us and then
i start laughing and among us
uncontrollably five months in i'm like
okay yeah we learn from the charity
stream that god's funny bone is just
someone saying among us but just bass
boost
and you'll just laugh
do you get like annoyed people like you
don't sound canadian anymore i feel like
attacked people say that to me when
they're like you don't sound british
enough i know what you mean yeah like
i'm [ __ ] born there what do you mean
what is this right now like i really do
this is a safe space for like a podcast
wait wait so how how long were you in
canada for
um
between the ages of four to twenty it's
like 16 years oh okay yeah okay yeah
okay be honest with me and like i can
take it how american do i sound oh yeah
like very like a hundred people yeah i i
did yeah yeah
i'm american or like i live in l.a no
american american i'm american because
like americans
like saying american accent is just like
the most neutral accent you could ask
it's like the default skin in fortnite
that's what they meant to be able to
tell a canadian from an american if the
canadian didn't have like an intense
canadian accent because i don't think a
lot of us are out here like
this
i mean there are some people there are
some people i've met that have like that
kind of you know a buddha yeah yeah but
like i've i've met so many creators just
on this trip alone yeah where i'm like i
always thought you were american
until you told me like like you for
example like i didn't know you were
canadian you know so it's like
it's it's really hard to hear something
i mean obviously if you're like you know
from quebec or something or like you
know where it's like a very strong
accent right yeah yeah obviously if
you're xqc i can tell you're not quite
from america but like yeah for your
accent i have no idea you just sound
american to me for me i can't tell the
difference between american and canadian
accents but sometimes you get like you
meet someone and they just like they
have the canadian energy you know what i
mean
i can tell you the canadian energy is
when you go into a place and you say hey
can i go to the bathroom
the toilet not like the washroom or like
where can i go
you know it's like specific words wait
when you say bagel i thought i thought i
thought bathroom was like what americans
say is a washroom
i've never heard anyone say wash fruit
i've never heard anything
yeah do they say toilet in america can i
go to the toilet fred like in french
they say toilet in america
i don't even i don't i mostly hear the
word bathroom yeah like okay then i
meant washroom i think when i first came
to l.a i used to say washroom a lot of
people were like
yeah that's kind of like when you're an
american you just say where's the loo
you know i don't know well like actually
we say that we see a toilet in the uk
right yeah we say we see toilet oh my
god oh my god have you have you
forgotten connor have you forgotten i i
do forget because i've been so
americanized
yeah
and everyone gives me so much copia
i did a [ __ ] stream with ludwig and
he made a video about it and it was oh i
was doing well then a lot of the
comments were like i was waiting for the
british guy to turn up because there's a
british guy in the title and uh this guy
isn't british i live lived in britain
and he doesn't sound british and it's
like
if i'm around british people it goes
british if i'm around american people it
goes more american yeah okay
random thought
curious what you guys think do you think
like actors and celebrities that are
known for being from a certain place
will intentionally try to like continue
to force their accent for a really long
time because i could see that like
they'll move to america or something be
here for a long time maybe lose the
accent but then they like have to
retrain themselves to keep the accent
dude i feel like i have to dream
nice yeah yeah yeah like he's about to
start doing that i i i have to do that
so actually i've been doing that for a
very long time um
i feel i feel especially like something
about like the american accent is very
easily transferred
yeah yeah it's just speaking you're just
you're just enunciating all your work
except for h that's that's the only
thing uh you know yeah
h
herbs
herbs that's the only thing i don't
understand everything else i'm like okay
it makes sense why you kind of like made
it very clear and
very enunciated that's how you say it
right yeah enunciated
yeah yeah yeah and the other thing is
i heard that listen british accents are
so fun to do
i don't actually have it so let me
pretend my friends are bullying me as
well like tuesday water yeah
[ __ ] it um
um canadians say xyz not xyz we say xyz
as well yeah
yeah same with the british hell yeah my
man yeah are you as canadian say zed
yeah i always say zed so because you
used to be britain
i guess
everywhere
the rights to this accent as well
no
absolutely not
it depends how [ __ ] it is
yeah that's that's how we that's how we
decide if we're offended or not like if
your accent's really [ __ ] then it's like
all right you better work on it before
you talk to me yeah yeah yeah
do you feel like uh you have a bond to
the queen as your as your head of state
growing up a little bit because i think
we're talking no i kid you not okay we
were taught that quite a bit in school
but then afterwards i'm like queen who
what yeah i'm not american i'm not
canadian
i i belong to the world
so can you go back to your like
i guess like your accent you grew up
with any time you want to because i
guess it wasn't that much of an
it depends like where abouts in canada
were you from like were you from like
vancouver or like
i was from middle of buff like nowhere
calgary
no actually the accents that you guys
probably think of when you think of
canadian accents
are from the like middle provinces yeah
manitoba alberta yeah very who mega lol
i'm the kind of who megalo that's like
i'm two hours from toronto so i pretend
i'm from toronto but i'm not i'm from a
very boring little city right right
right right so you have the small town
rep right i guess a little bit yeah just
a small town girl
no honestly the older i get them this
sounds so the more appreciative i am of
my upcoming because
i feel like it was just so chill like a
small pretty wholesome like
kind of multicultural town and
living in america you i feel like you
are much more exposed
oh yeah to all the downsides of living
in america not just living in america
you're living in l.a as well you know
yeah a very very intense city it's
couldn't be pretty much the opposite of
what you grew up in exactly so yeah so
yeah we always ask this to every el
person who now lives in l.a do you enjoy
living in l.a
because i swear every person we've met
just on this trip alone who lives here
is just like yeah so so what's it like
living in l.a and 90 of them are like
it's [ __ ]
but i can't leave i can't say it's [ __ ]
but you do feel a little bit like a
prisoner
sorry not
like how you can feel imprisoned in like
a toxic relationship that's the best way
to put it it's like i just can't chains
of the mind but there are major
downsides but there are major upsides so
i can't say it's great like i'm very
loving and i mean prison has upsides as
well you know free food yeah free
accommodation you know this is this
there's an upside down yeah there's some
things no okay la is really not that bad
obviously or else i wouldn't live there
yeah um
but it really is
it's a toxic relationship right would
you ever consider moving out if you know
you you know wanted to take some time
off or twitch or whatever she would i
think for starters i could not possibly
imagine raising a family in los angeles
yeah i don't know how people
do that
i really don't but the weirder parts are
still trying to figure out sex yes
think about this the next time you guys
are out just think about i guess like
how many kids you see you don't see any
yeah yeah exactly
alyssa do the babies go
i guess they get shipped off to other
parts of america
qx files theme
i gotta say it is weird
walking past high schools in the middle
of [ __ ] like hollywood yeah and just
seeing like barricades on these schools
like i couldn't imagine going to a
school that looks like a prison
and that's that's why like i'm really
grateful i feel like i grew up
albeit maybe it was a little bit like a
naive way to grow up i think it's good
to be a little more on the sheltered i
have some naivety right now
exactly the moment you go online it's
all gone so you want to enjoy it how
long have you lived in l.a uh about
five years five years okay okay so like
four years and like streamer houses um
yeah what's what's what's what's next i
say this because some of them were
most of them were officially streamer
houses like i lived with otv but then i
lived with streamers but we weren't like
we were a house of content creators we
didn't like make content together yeah
yeah yeah right yeah and then i decided
to live alone which is enjoying it so
far
yeah yeah because uh
yeah when pokey first came here we were
like apologizing for how messy our house
is which to me
look at our house it's a [ __ ] mess
which it is and she was like no no this
this is like a clean house and i'm like
we haven't vacuumed in two weeks because
this house for some reason doesn't have
a vacuum so it's it's like it doesn't
have a lot of sleep mess yeah so when it
comes to cleanliness after being in like
content creator houses for four years my
standards are on the ground
and everything else is on the ground too
can i ask you what can i say i was the
most gross thing you've seen yeah
you don't have to name names
because like i lived there like i'm not
saying i'm the cleanest person i'm
saying it's just messy um but very much
like it's typically like junk or like
food stuff
especially because
you usually don't have designated people
for specific tasks right yeah taking out
the trash yeah yeah because you're all
and details we got those little like
zapper thingies oh yeah
and every now and then you hear a large
zap because it's a fly who's like
and everyone turns around like just
another dead fly yeah because it just
kind of sounds like a frat house right
because i was yeah i was gonna ask do
you do did you have like a cleaning
rotor where you know you take turns
cleaning the house or was it just
whoever was like the most disgusted
first cleaned the house hey to be fair
we would have cleaners come every maybe
like two weeks
um it's just it's hard to manage that
many people without having someone be
like you do this and you do this and you
do that and when you're in a group of
friends like no one really wants to do
that right of course and i i think i
ended up not being the cleanest either
but i would just try to be as messy as
possible in my room right right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then i get
bothered by myself and i have to clean
up after myself and run right how's your
apartment now then is it is it clean is
it [ __ ] and spam or is it is it the same
the same pokey streamer house i think
it's pretty nice right now i still have
a lot of like moving unpacking well i'll
ask you again in two weeks and see if
the answer is the same
if you've just moved in that doesn't
count because yeah it's it's always
always classy yeah insane
and then for me it's like my environment
is a reflection of my brain like if i'm
stressed before a trip everything's
everywhere and i'm gone because i just
like spent the last five hours packing
yeah yeah oh no but like the worst
feeling is when you come back you're
[ __ ] exhausted from the flight you've
you've had a great time and you come
back and the house is a [ __ ] mess
get a cleaner while you're gone
see money you come home and you're like
i live it feels very like blobby like
your mom cleaned you know honestly
that's like
wow family no it's just a cleaner you
paid like a hundred dollars to clean
honestly that's that's what i love
saying about in like about staying about
in hotels you know you go out you go out
the room's a [ __ ] mess and you're
like i know it's gonna be clean when
they come when i come back
yeah i know it's gonna be [ __ ] and spam
and i can have a good night's sleep so
yeah
so you've obviously um like moving on
now from like to like the twitch stuff
right because it's like how long have
you been doing twitch now i feel like
you've been on the platform forever like
nine years geez
eight to nine years somewhere in between
there my god that's insane you're still
enjoying it obviously
or is that a loaded question
yeah
obviously generally net positive right
youtube you know yeah yeah it's just
like youtube but you've seen the
platform change so much like it's
completely different because like
obviously i haven't been doing it as
long as you but like even just in the
short amount of time i've been doing
twitch it's like changed [ __ ]
dramatically right not just the platform
but the audience
right
it becomes like more diversified with
every year which i
can't say enough how much i appreciate
yeah right i mean like with in terms of
the countries or just in general
interests and everything like that in
general interests gender espec
especially
uh countries a little bit but i feel
like it kind of grows
everywhere all at once right right yeah
because i guess when you started
was it mostly males that were on twitch
you played league right yeah so that's
just oh i'm sorry
thank you yeah
my condolences
we both played a lot of league
yeah we both played a long league so we
get it as well yeah oh yeah yeah do you
guys remember like back in the day
especially when league was always like
the most popular on twitch
what was like running rampant was these
videos talking about like
female twitch streamers and cleavage
like that was the thing yeah that was
the click bait everywhere and it was
like
almost like this propaganda that spread
across and i was like this is where you
find
you know
hot single ladies in your
area single league players in your area
they don't exist
because twitch was so new that was like
the first thing to like virally
circulate about female streamers oh my
god she wore this oh my god she did that
she was donated this much and it's just
been like so so many years and so much
work to kind of move past that and be
like yeah there's women of all types
just like in real life yeah right who
knew yeah
what a shock yeah so how have you like
dealt with
that kind of culture because if if
there's anyone who's gone through like
we've talked about we've talked a lot
about you know toxic online culture a
lot in our podcast but if there's anyone
who's been through toxic online culture
it is you
so if there's someone we could we could
actually take advice from it's probably
you you your advice what's wrong oh
you've been on like you've been all like
the
i'm good
nothing's inherently wrong but like
you've been on the forefront of
literally every
war or battle when it comes to that side
of things on the internet yeah you are
so it's like i don't know it's just i
think it'd be really interesting to hear
from your perspective about like what
you've seen and what you've gone through
yeah and like you're honest opinions on
it yeah sure um
where do i even start
how do you begin like what what was your
starting first starters
again i think i was really naive like i
came on twitch just to make friends to
play video games with because in this
small town i knew like
two peop two girls and like four guys
that i would game with yeah that's why
we started making youtube videos as well
yeah exactly and like the two girls
don't even play games anymore and i'm
like i need flint you know i was 17 just
wanted to have fun right and i kept
doing it uh part time and i have been on
the internet since i was like 11 or 10
yeah yeah like i know that there will
always be some weird comments um creepy
person some whatever so i was very
accustomed to that
and i grew up with an older brother so i
was very used to bullying
i'm kidding not bullying but like if
anything a lot of banter like he would
talk some [ __ ] i would talk some [ __ ]
yeah now we're besties who play
volleyball together but
um
so like i
guess i was just very used to that yeah
so streaming i didn't like especially
just starting off i was like oh this is
normal you'll get weird comments here
and there yeah but oddly enough i feel
like
let me know if you guys agree like way
back in the day before
all these social platforms and twitch
and content creation in general blew up
i actually feel like the internet was a
little more uh like almost like
wholesome and welcoming because there
weren't as many people yeah
that deep into it yeah yeah i was just
about to say it really felt like all the
um like around 2015-16 when obviously
all the political stuff was happening it
kind of just shifted into the online
thing yeah yeah with all the metoo stuff
as well where everyone had to pick a
side with it so it was just it just
became this you versus them and then if
you were a woman online who had uh yeah
yeah and then there so i imagine that
was that when it started picking you up
absolutely but like when i was like 12
13 14 15 and i would make friends online
and someone found out i was a girl they
were actually really nice yeah yeah nice
of playing maplestory and meeting a guy
one time and he was like oh i'm gonna
quit and he found out i was a girl and
he gave me all his loot everything he
had been grinding for like three years
and he was like well i'm actually
quitting today so that is the most
that's the most maple story
maple story
[Music]
that was my that was probably my first
like simping interaction
and i could tell in that moment i was
like i think he's treating this me this
way because of my gender but it's very
nice
so i'll take it well yeah i mean as a as
a former maple story player yeah i can i
can like attest to that being like
because you know everyone would play the
game and obviously you could pick like
your avatars and whatnot but it was an
actual rare occurrence when it's like
you're a female character and you're a
female irl legit like girls were like
unicorns in the gaming yeah yeah but in
the way where we were like treated much
nicer because we were rare yeah exactly
exactly i don't know how this went so
sound
yo as a former league player how many
times did the jungler camp your lane
just when they found out you were a girl
actually
league i had i guess a different
experience because people get very angry
oh yeah yeah
um and if anything that was when i
started feeling like oh my gender is
something to be used against me like
yeah oh if you're not playing well it's
because of this part of you
like oh my genitals dictate how good i
am of the game on but sure
right um yeah so i think that's when it
like really first started for me but
also with league i would play a lot with
friends and i kind of chalked up
a lot of negative experiences to like oh
just random angry people online it's
just league that's that's just the
league experience at the end of the day
right you were good though right you
were like diamond rank right higher dude
when i grinded i was pretty [ __ ]
gonna leave like i saw you to like d1 or
something on stream as well yeah but
like way back in the day and the thing
is like when you're a casual player yeah
and like these are the streams you know
you have like taller one yeah double
lift yeah
you know yeah when
i'm being compared to these guys who are
obviously insane challenges and i'm like
a casual player like trying my best
above average but like you have bad
games d1 is better than your entire chat
though probably at that point like d1
people see you have a bad game they're
like this is my opportunity to say
because you're up girl nah dude it's
because i'm a casual player and
everybody has bad games all the time
like yeah you're not at your peak
capabilities 24 7. yeah and streaming
[Music]
yeah like how much pressure was on you
as like one of the top like the top
female streamer for like a while to like
feel like you had to be like the perfect
person or like the perfect role model
even though you're human just like
everyone else
a lot
and sometimes still to this day it's
just a little bit tough because i feel
like i have to
overthink a lot of the decisions that i
make in order for it to reflect well
yeah on this group an entire gender if
anything that i am unintentionally
representing yeah so like when i decide
to do something um even if it's
something as simple as like i went from
playing league to doing like variety
content yeah if i don't work my ass off
to make that transition
work well in my favor
like oh like finally she like fell off
or this or that right no you can just
people are waiting to celebrate
yeah like they're so ready to write
whatever negative narrative you have to
work so hard to create a positive one
for example like when i first started
streaming i saw a lot of people
um
like a lot of people when a girl was
doing well they'd be like oh it's
because you're dating this person yeah
so they would attribute that female
streamer's success to their partner so i
was like okay i'm never going to date
anyone publicly that way anything i do
will be accredited to me
i thought
no they will just find another way to do
this yeah yeah yeah exactly and instead
it became like a who is she dating she's
hiding her boyfriend for donations and
subs and this and that and i'm like
i'm either doing this bad there's no way
i'm doing i'm either like clout chasing
if someone is more popular than me or if
someone was less popular than me i'd be
using him yeah if i had him involved you
know yeah or you're pandering to like
the simps or something right yeah
you do
can be seen negatively that's really
what i've learned
my time
so how do you stay positive then it says
it sounds like you're revolution
yeah do you just like i guess it's just
like you just stop giving a [ __ ] i guess
it's like
partially but honestly what helped me a
lot was um
my female streamer friends like if i
didn't have them validating me and being
like no like from an objective
perspective telling me there are
instances like obviously i i mess up and
i apologize for the situations where i
do mess up yeah but i feel like so many
things get like convoluted taken out
yeah yeah yeah yeah
just narratives being spread like
wildfire to make me look bad if i didn't
have
other people that i trusted objectively
saying like no you are being treated
unfairly in comparison to other people
in similar positions yeah i would have
gone crazy
myself to heck
but
luckily i did have like a really really
great support system okay and i think
like once i got to a point where i
realized oh wow this is like a male
dominated field
look at the podcast
you guys are the good ones
the good one the good one because we're
not in l.a that's my favorite that's
you're going to see it
no but
it was also like there's been so many
weird moments in this industry for
example even realizing like
i knew
need the help of other
like men in my field male content
creators male streamers yeah
because and as
unfortunately misogynistic as this is a
lot of the audience will only really
trust something if it's coming from
another guy that they respect so we need
you guys to say women good for me to be
okay
women good
women good guys guys woman good yeah
yeah guys we all agree with that right
right connor is that really the case
oh yeah and it's especially it's so
depressing i never thought of it
i never thought about it like that yeah
sorry i'm getting so into this we could
talk about anything yeah it's actually
really interesting
particular there's like so much to go
off of not just that yeah but knowing
that and that being very very clear to
me
multiple instances it made me especially
sad when this whole like sim narrative
became a thing yeah right because then i
could very much sense my male friends
were having a hard time standing up for
me or defending me in situations because
they didn't want to be deemed oh you're
just a samp you're this you're that and
look down yeah so there was
yeah there was just like like god forbid
platonic relationships
god forbid you say something good about
a girl yeah the thing i always found
weird about that is that
there seems to be like okay let's say if
uh if if a woman actually was trying to
push the the boyfriend experience and
trying to push that yeah it's not like
guys don't do it inversely yeah yeah the
thing that i've never really found i
found really weird is because as a guy i
see other sometimes i see other content
creators really going for that angle of
like i'm i'm like i'm gonna be your
boyfriend or i'm you know giving you
that experience this video is sponsored
by expressvpn big tech is more powerful
than most countries are and they are
profiting by exploiting your personal
data how dare they it's time to put a
layer of protection between your online
activity and these tech juggernauts and
that's why i use expressvpn guys just
think about how much of your life is on
the internet
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send gets
tracked and data mined but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address something big tech
can use to personally identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers what i
like most about xpressvpn is how easy it
is to use it it really is easy to use it
is actually easy one button uh i got it
right here on my phone just download the
app on your phone computer tap one
button and you're protected so stop
handing over your personal data to big
tech monopolies that mine your activity
and sell your information protect
yourself with the vpn that we trust to
keep us safe online visit expressvpn.com
trash taste that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trashtaste to get three months extra for
free go to expressvpn.com trash taste
right now to learn more back to the
episode it's not like there aren't
male craters doing or pushing even
further for the whole boyfriend
experience of like i love you so much
you guys mean so much to me and yeah oh
by the way here's my is my 30 minute asm
arm of me telling me how much i love you
and it's like people like would never
ever ever criticize people who do that
publicly but if for some reason it's
okay when it's a woman i don't
understand that's
another major realization that was very
helpful to me because for a long time i
was like am i doing something wrong like
people saying sympathies and that but
i'm like i don't think i go out of mind
you don't even yeah you don't yeah like
do that kind of i just love gaming um i
love to do whatever kind of sorry
whatever kind of content i happen to be
in a very male dominated field and then
i realized like wait a second like so
many very very very popular guys have
female majority audiences yeah and
no one ever uses that as an insult
towards them yeah or uses that to
discredit them in any way well it's just
the filthy double standards all right
it's just like oh it's it's it's like a
low-key blew my mind because i'm like
especially like most male artists think
justin bieber when he was young or even
bts now or like maybe even some male
streamers as well yeah and another thing
yeah and another thing as well is like
you you are
it's recently the v tubing trend has
like popped off right i remember
especially in the early days of v tubing
they were definitely like it's if if
they were a 3d girl you know you you
know we don't sit for the 3d girls but
it's fine to like sim for the 2d girls
right and it's fine for the youtubers
like some of the really early youtubers
to really play that up you know oh yeah
exactly and like nowadays now it's it's
it's the male youtubers that are playing
it up and
it's completely okay oh yeah i never
thought about it yeah now now it's like
you know yeah like some especially even
in japan like some of the top uh v
tubers in some industries now are male
oriented with massive female oriented
audiences because obviously you know the
idol culture is massive in japan right
and yeah
no one bats an eye meanwhile 3d streamer
who's a female does it and everyone
loses their minds right yeah i always
thought oh sorry go go for it i also
think maybe one of the reasons why is
because i feel like youtubing
and youtubers in general um appeal to an
audience to whom
like that maybe isn't as weird or
they're not like
as ready like if you watch anime there
probably is a waifu that you love right
right um so for that to be a v tuber
instead and be a streamer like that's
probably a cool experience for you
whereas when it comes to gaming over
time i learned there are you know a lot
of people that might tend to be more
misogynistic i don't know the right way
to see these to say these things
that also happened to just heck and love
gaming but those types of people don't
really like anime so they won't go and
hate on a popular youtuber right that's
right their interest is gaming not anime
yeah
you kind of know what i'm saying
guys are so
worried about being like what the [ __ ] i
didn't do anything i'm not misogynistic
and so when they when
you it's hard to have these
conversations because a lot of guys feel
attacked when they're like oh you're
you're successful because you're a male
and it's like no that's not what we're
saying it's it's different it's
you are more likely to be successful
because you are a male because of a
number of factors and you can't deny
that as a male you would have advantages
in certain areas like that's just how
life is that's how like society has been
made society we live in a society
society
that's just how it is right and to not
accept that and and be willing to be
like hey that's what it is but [ __ ] it i
can i can still make [ __ ] i can do my
own thing like yeah for something i'm
not addicted to people what's wrong with
that yeah nothing wrong with calling it
out and saying
here's how it is
yeah did you ever feel like because
there was a point where i feel there was
like so much pressure on you that like
you said you it felt like you're in a
like a lose-lose situation right where
you know like you know a lot of the guys
were being like you know
trying to discredit you your if anyone
tried to defend you they were like
labeled as a simp or something like that
and
i i feel like you even got a lot of
criticism from like a lot of girls like
being like oh no this is she's
representing girls wrong or she's like
bringing a bad name for
you know female streams and stuff like
that i actually feel like that's one of
the things i got the least of sometimes
okay okay well really not that often if
anything
the girls were one of the things that
kept me going yeah because i feel like
no one better understands the struggle
than other female streamers than other
girls in that game then
you know or really any minority within
gaming kind of understands what that
what that experience is right
and the craziest part of all of this and
the sim stuff is whatever is like any
time i like pull my twitch audience or
like really get any analytics from that
i have way more female yeah like
gender not non-binary or any other kind
of gendered um statistics than the
majority of male streamers right right
so they can make it make sense do you
remember how this whole thing started
like the whole sim movement thing
started or was it something just like it
was just like an internet phenomenon if
anything i i don't know i don't want to
speculate too much but i feel like maybe
at some point
uh
people saw like girls doing really well
yeah yeah yeah clock that their
viewers or guys or that they got a
certain type of energy i don't know why
maybe for some people that like
it
makes them feel jealous potentially
right right or to them it just doesn't
really make sense
they don't even want to try to
understand it or you know whatever
because i think yeah definitely i think
there was like a a very you know a very
long period where it was it was a very
gradual rise of like oh
girls play games and stream too guys
it's like whoa what the [ __ ] you know so
it's like i think it's from there that's
when it started to kind of this movement
of like just people who clearly were
never in the right mindset to begin with
who was suddenly like wow
look at all these men conforming to
these female streamers what just because
they're good at league now they're
suddenly they're your wife it's like no
they're just they're just entertaining
people and they just want to like watch
their favorite stream or regardless of
their gender it's like maybe the other
thing is um
i think it is really really hard to
break through
on twitch yeah yeah absolutely it's such
a saturated platform yeah
three four years ago when it wasn't a
saturated it was still hard then yeah
and it's especially hard when you're the
100 thousandth guy to stream yeah but
when you're a girl because you're like
more rare or more of a minority on
twitch
they're like the ssr pools on twitch
sometimes you can have an easier start
only start not middle yeah
but sometimes you can have an easier
time gaining initial traction again
because you stick out in comparison to
all the other
uh smaller or newer streamers and i
think when they see this like advantage
in a sense
i can understand people being upset at
that like
no i don't have the ability to do that
right and then they twist it into
like i guess viewing that person's
gender negatively or being like oh it's
just because people are simping for them
like they turned
i guess this situation
into just calling other people yeah yeah
to discredit whatever viewership or
success that person yeah i'd say you're
in the category of just like just a
normal stream who is a girl right yeah
and i think the the what the reason why
it's a really [ __ ] annoying
conversation to have about all of this
stuff is because
there is a
some people who stream on twitch who
happen to be women who definitely push
the [ __ ] envelope like yeah just just
take the piss with what like should be
allowed yeah
is it
is it frustrating when you feel that
like you're trying to kind of
like push like hey we can do this stuff
and then you just flip over to the other
category and this woman that's naked
literally slobbering on like an ear like
yeah how do you
how do you deal with that okay i
actually had a freaking
epiphany regarding this okay right years
ago
mainly when as i said like there was all
this variety yeah virality around like
this girl shows cleavage and games like
she's yeah
yeah yeah she's doing this right
no i kid you know but back then like
those were almost the only girls that
could have like 2k plus viewers aside
from maybe like khafu during her pro
like casey tron was that what it was
yeah she wasn't mean but like yeah that
was crazy yeah
she's so funny yeah um so
that really
those kind of were the top female
structures
at a very initial point on twitch and at
that time
i
there was like some frustration i think
for a lot of female streamers because
they're like people come into our chats
and they either expect this or
you know they label all female streamers
as this one thing right
even in college when i told people that
i streamed they're like you're a cam
girl
no no i'm on a webcam
so i turn on the computer i stream
online to thousands of viewers and they
give me money sometimes i don't know why
they why do i think i'm a cam girl i
don't know that's like when you try and
explain your streaming career to like
your grandma
you know it's like it's like the most
like rudimentary like youtube i don't
know what a cam goes yeah
so initially there were some
frustrations where it's like you know i
feel like
right yeah but i remember um
someone told me once they were like
you shouldn't be upset at the female
streamers who are doing that you should
be upset at the guys who are expecting
you to do the same thing just because
they saw someone else do it or for guys
who are having one assumption about an
entire gender based off of one person
that they saw yeah and i was like
true
third eye opens
because it is difficult not to be
frustrated when you feel like there's a
negative stereotype yeah
not be upset at the people perpetuating
that yeah but also if anything i'd be
more annoyed at like the people click
baiting them um and like trying to
sensationalize it yeah like if homegirl
wants to make her money go make your
money yeah yeah especially nowadays like
you don't have to be mad at all because
it's it's been made much more clear like
streamers can come in all sorts of types
and right yeah yeah
that's a really interesting point
because i think part of the problem was
that talking about the problem just
became as profitable as like the pro
problem itself yeah like which made it
seem like a bigger problem than it is
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah
like the the rise of especially
commentary and drama youtubers within
like the past five years just like kind
of coincided with this kind of witch
hunt
triggering
yeah that's like a similar thought to i
think we spoke about this before on the
podcast it's like um
you know how uh sometimes people are
like you know uh parents should treat uh
should teach women how to like avoid
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] weird dudes and
it's like and i think someone uh
commented on long lines of like uh it
was like uh no you should
parents should teach their uh male kids
to not be [ __ ] freaks yeah yeah yeah
yeah which is true yeah yeah you like
solve the issue from the most
fundamental place and not yeah all the
way up at the top yeah i think
unfortunately it's just easier to like
pick on like one public target rather
than just a lot of faceless masses
because then it's just like well society
right
there's nothing there's nothing we can
do about it yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah you were so right there was like a
period of time where it was especially
profitable to
pick on people or make videos about them
or speak negatively on on them yeah
regardless of what platform they were on
youtube twitch tick tock yeah
every week
yeah and for a long time like i felt
really bad about myself because i was
like i'm that problematic man
you just had it no you were too
successful your name was worth a lot and
it would get clicked that's
and it's hard
um i i guess almost like math or like
logically it's hard not to think like oh
maybe i am the problem right and not to
say that i'm a perfect person but in
hindsight it just had a lot to do with
the position that i was in like if
if you would put any other person and
name on the channel that i was on it
would be their names in those titles
instead exactly exactly and the thing is
because because of like the problem that
your name was just so
i guess like recognizable
and clickable like you do like one thing
and i swear like people were just making
[ __ ] nine part series on this like
one thing that was like barely an issue
to begin with yeah and it was just like
and people clicked on it and it's it was
unfortunate at the time i don't know if
it still was prevalent nowadays but
there was definitely a time i think it's
i don't think it's as prevalent nowadays
because i think now there's a lot of
commentary channels who have now opted
towards the route of like we're not
going to necessarily give our opinions
on this thing yeah we're just going to
state the facts and what we know and
it's up to you to decide yeah what you
want to take out of it yeah but at the
same time i think what a lot of those
channels don't understand is that
their audiences for the most part aren't
as intelligent enough to just make up
their own opinions you know usually they
go to those videos because they want
them they want the tea you know they
want the drama they want an opinion to
get behind whatever you're covering yeah
whose sides are you showing how much how
deep are you really looking exactly are
you showing the first report you saw on
dixterra with that shitty [ __ ]
articles
that's been oh yeah yeah i was gonna ask
yeah so
i i've recently started getting these i
don't know if this means that i'm doing
well i think that means i'm doing well
yeah i think so it's like it'll be like
twitch star c dog [ __ ] took iron
masks to a park on stream and it was
wholesome and then there'll be another
one it's like
twitch star [ __ ] exceed i love the word
twitch star so i call myself uh
twitch star c dog falls a jump king and
it's like that's not newsworthy they do
this for everything really every they'll
be like xqc had an opinion here it is
yeah no but sometimes
is it just me man like they write that
crazy [ __ ]
okay what what are they right what do
they write okay i have this kind of joke
that i've made i think three times okay
which is i have these two cats that i
love so much um and i care a lot like
i'm so invested in my cat are you
chilling okay yeah yeah yeah um but
sometimes i you know my mind goes so far
i'm like
i think my cat should roam free
[Music]
okay okay
okay okay okay
you know it was born an animal i'm
imprisoning it
it has like a two thousand dollar cat
tree a five hundred dollars yeah
like a high quality tuna three times a
day every cat owner knows the cat owns
you yeah you do not know
the cat does what it wants yeah you you
are the cat servant yeah it's it's
living a good life are very good at
surviving on their own it will it will
be fine but like you know my mind goes
this far and i'm like you know it's my
dream i want to live on a farm but it's
in clothes and an enclosed farm so it
can roam free but i never have to worry
about it like going too far yeah okay so
how does this leave free range
right okay sorry yeah so
one day i was making this joke
just like i did to you guys right what
does a dexcerto dextero article say it
says
pokemane breaks down
to a farm or something
i hope i hope they make a parody one
from this this podcast yeah yeah
i really hope you did
and then my mom calls me she's like
sweetie are you okay
i'm in the know valerie like what what's
wrong she's like i read an article
no i i don't mind the articles it's just
like what the [ __ ] what are these what
are these titles i don't know it's just
interesting how they choose to
sensationalize them but it's
detailed it really made me realize like
whether it's youtube clickbait or random
articles online people will believe
anything they can read yeah
it's true yeah unfortunately it's gone
to the point where you're just bombarded
with so much [ __ ] that you read like one
headline and you're like yeah okay i
guess that happened you know
and
it's just a slow news day
yeah
now with like [ __ ] tweet longers
being entire dissertations you're like
i can't read through all this just like
sometimes
i'm not literate yeah i'm like i feel i
feel bad i feel bad but sometimes i'm
just like just tell me how to think it's
right like i i don't have the time to
get it i think it's both like human
nature it's sometimes just easier to
agree with someone when they make sense
and it feels good you're like yeah
that's true when they're passionate
about it you're like you have energy for
this yeah i don't go ahead i have energy
to agree which is out here
yeah but the and also i think we're so
as you said like overwhelmed with
information
different titles and comments and this
and that and that it's hard to tell what
is like true or not especially when
someone is like confident and it sounds
like it makes sense like good enough for
me
but that's been very difficult in my
position and it sometimes just feels
like i have to go so out of my way to
correct
all the random things other people are
saying yeah that's exhausting
those people are gonna believe whatever
they want right if you if if they see
this article they're gonna believe it
and even if the article didn't exist
they're gonna make up [ __ ] in their head
why they don't like you but you know
what's sad i actually kind of disagree i
think there is like let's say
yeah i think there's like a group of
people yeah they will believe anything
negative about you and you cannot
convince them
out of it because they didn't convince
themselves into it they wanted to hate
you from yeah yeah yeah but i think
there is like quite a
like quite a big group of people
that might just have gotten the wrong
impression or believed something is that
big i don't think it's that big i i i
think that like it's hard to truly
qualify you'll go insane trying to
correct all the false [ __ ] about you
online and maybe it's not big maybe it's
not a big deal but like just trying to
correct all the stuff all the time it's
like why do i give a [ __ ] about this let
me just play video games i really don't
[ __ ] care i think um like it depends
for example like nowadays it's not
something that bothers me as much right
right but during a very specific like
year or two of my career for sure that
felt like the majority of my life like
and i especially guys i didn't kick my
cat
okay
i noticed because like again months or
like a year or two later i had a lot of
people like an influx of people that i
would see everywhere just saying like oh
i'm sorry like i had a really bad
impression of you because of xyz but now
i realize you're normal
yeah a lot of those kind of comments
so cause you get
i think what can happen is as well and
it's it's nothing like it's not that bad
but
you you see all this stuff about you
online and people are saying these
things
and you get frustrated about it and then
the one thing that i've had to like try
and dial back personally as well i was
like try not to give too much
frustration uh often stream or publicly
because in it some people see that and
then it's like i just don't like this
energy yeah they don't like it and that
freaks them out yeah and then they'll
get a bad impression yeah yeah right
it's not even about what you say it's
about how you say oh yeah yeah that's
what makes it believable or not
essentially no definitely yeah well
yeah then even if people continue to
talk bad about you if you continue to
address it even if it's a complete slam
dunk and you're completely right and the
guy's a clown you're like you're you're
still people will be like well he he's
kind of like getting a bit too involved
in this right he's carrying a bit too
much he's a bit too defensive right yeah
yeah yeah like it's something you're too
involved in drama people just think
you're sauce yeah yeah yeah even if
you're like what are you hiding yeah
yeah yeah yeah why so desperate it's
just i don't know yeah yeah my my least
favorite thing with like ever coming
onto the internet to defend yourself
regardless of how big or small it is is
the argument i've seen it so many times
of like well that's the price of having
fame
yeah it's like it's like you're out
there you put yourself out there you're
famous now so you should just be like
used to this and i'm like yeah no
no this should not be normal still a
human being yeah you're still a human
being at the end of the day like you can
say that because you've never been in
these people's positions right yeah we
were british though so it doesn't count
[Music]
because i think out of the three of us
the only one who's ever had to
make an apology video i think is just
joey yeah and that was for like looking
back looking back i'm like what this is
the most ridiculous reason to make an
apology it was wacky
yeah it was whack as [ __ ] so it was when
um do you know the anime yuri on ice
i've heard of it you know the ice
skating one yeah yeah so there was a
massive obviously because of the
of the subject matter of the show and
how it kind of you know plays out it has
a very massive female audience right
yeah even though it is technically a
sports
manga or anime yeah so i made this i
made this one joke where i said like no
99 of the people who watch this show
watch it for the boy on boy action yeah
and one percent of them watch it for the
actual sport yeah and uh yeah and and
twitter went off
they went off on me and obviously this
is the first time where i think because
of where i was where my channel was at
the time yeah uh i'd never really gotten
that much backlash before because i've
been saying my opinion for years now you
know a lot of hot takes but at the end
of the day it's whatever you know it's
just an opinion of mine but i think i
really underestimated
how far an opinion can go about a show
especially with a dedicated fan base so
i just woke up one morning to just like
countless comments i get pissed off
hearing you talk about shows
because i think it's just like i think
the way you talk about shows sometimes
are like dismissive and it makes people
feel like why won't you [ __ ] give it
a chance
here's the thing you're a nice thing i
watch the entire show yeah right and i
enjoyed
some parts of it i didn't think it was
the most amazing show yeah but i thought
some parts of it did pretty well you
didn't like it so then they were like
you didn't like it yeah yeah and and
because it is basically you know a show
that is targeted towards a certain
demographic in a lot of ways yeah
immediately people were like he's a
misogynist
he's like he he's he's homophobic he's
misogynist he just doesn't like things
that we women enjoy
so my apology was just face up you take
it down oh no i took it down yeah i took
it down but like uh you know in
hindsight that was it was completely
unnecessary yeah because i think that's
the moment i uploaded it and then i
realized when i read the comments of
that apology video like ninety percent
of them were like dude you didn't have
to pause well the first time the first
time you you get like a i guess a bunch
of hate overnight in one go is probably
the the scariest yeah yeah and for me
that was the first time where like i
just woke up and it was just like all
these new people who were just like
giving me [ __ ] and just calling me names
and i'm like
[ __ ] this is the end of my career i'm
[ __ ] right so i feel very pressured oh
yeah absolutely so i took action and
then immediately after i uploaded that
video and i started to see the first
wave of comments of dude it's fine you
didn't have to apologize for that
immediately took it down and i realized
that was a big mistake i shouldn't have
apologized yet so now i know if i say an
opinion i don't give a [ __ ]
i just like looking back i just i just
find it funny like especially with how
many people have made apology videos
yeah now it's just like you you look at
you look at the list and you're just
like oh what did you apologize for oh
you know i ran like a cs go gambling
scam yeah oh you know i was i
i said i said like i came on my cat oh
what did you apply for
yeah yeah so like but but you know again
like at that time i had no idea right
and because again i think i was just
like pressured into thinking oh maybe
i'm the bad guy because of this mass
audience of people online who were
saying how [ __ ] i was as a person for
giving this opinion yeah so i think i
mean obviously now i know because i've
experienced that and i've obviously
heard from other people's experiences
and whatnot but i think initially yeah
it was uh it means people are engaging
with your opinion no it's just good
because sometimes that means they're
getting angry but at least they're
engaging that's all that matters exactly
and i think you partner manager
we've seen like an uptick
but wouldn't it be even worse if nobody
gave a [ __ ] about what you said
are you saying it's just the curse of
being popular
is that what you're saying of if you
have opinions that's what comes with
faith
i i said i don't like some anime people
get really annoyed about it but it's
like you're wrong so
that's not my mom
you're not an anime i think is a you
know that's like a subject people are
very passionate you think so right you
think so you tell us later about your
opinions we'll get angry yeah
um i actually think this whole thing is
such an interesting premise like talking
about apology videos and whether or not
you regret them have you made that oh
i've made it
how many apologies have you heard how
crazy my life i
video where i apologize i apologize
about like four things okay right
wait when was this
um this was like at the peak of like all
the videos and all that everything way
before the pandemic and among us
actually not before maybe it was right
at the beginning right right um and
there are some things that i apologize
for that i absolutely stick by yeah so
what happened can i can you tell
i don't remember any of this
watching if you don't remember it's fine
that just means it was it wasn't
important
i remember it's just like how do i
summarize yeah tldr well what what do
you guys know
i guess i know people angry at you but i
never understood why yeah i
remember like different times like leafy
made nine videos in a row about you or
some [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah leafy made
a lot of videos about it right yeah i
guess the issues with
a lot of the things that people are mad
at me about is
it gets taken out of context so far and
then snowballed into one tidbit and then
like that's the thing that sticks with
people this is why i hate her because of
this but like you don't know the context
regarding nothing whatsoever yeah which
is probably like one of the things that
not to retract the apology but like in
hindsight i don't know if it made as
much sense to apologize but i apologize
about this one thing yeah
yeah there was this guy who when those
kind of videos were popular also made a
video about me um
like
legit just [ __ ] on me like that's it
but actually the thing is like i was
used to people [ __ ] on me at that
point what really pissed me off about
his video which i was what which i
didn't watch the whole thing but i was
watching through some of it on stream oh
this horse batman i know
bad call back
i was new yeah
only seven years ago
it's tough because like initially it's
like i would ignore all of this and then
i realized like
you need to respond in order to give
people something to respond
and then trying to find that middle
ground of like don't give everything
attention but give the right amount of
attention at the right time to the right
yes yeah it's hard well you have a right
to defend yourself yeah yeah so uh when
someone had linked me this and i was
like skimming through it i saw that he
was pulling up like random people's
images that had photos with me at like
meet and greets or icons or whatever and
then he was speaking negatively about
how they look in his video
as he's a v tuber by the way like he's
not showing his face right
[ __ ] on my fans for how they look
yeah so again it was like a a guy
talking about me and it's like you know
you can say whatever about me it's not
gonna be the first time that i hear it
yep yep but for you to pull up photos of
fans of mine and then for some reason be
talking about how they look in front of
your whole audience yeah yeah yeah and
like you know i do put myself out there
so maybe you can justify talking about
me right but these people and i know
like
if you're not a public figure that type
of
scrutiny yeah on a wide scale like you
just don't know how that might impact oh
yeah yeah yeah it [ __ ] with you exactly
i was just like this is
so wrong beyond belief and obviously i
was very passionate in that moment yeah
um and then i was like scrolling through
the video and i saw that like the video
was sponsored and i basically made a
comment about like
i cannot possibly understand why a
sponsor would watch a video not about
someone talking about me you know
there's plenty of those and obviously
like um
commentary type of videos deserve to be
sponsored obviously right yeah but
i was wondering like did they really
watch through this and see him [ __ ] on
someone for how they look like how much
they weigh or like whatever it is
and they thought that like this was good
content to like enable in a sense
because when you sponsor something like
you know you're promoting that type of
content yeah a lot of brands don't give
a single [ __ ] though yeah they're just
like i want to be on anything that gets
us a million views i i don't know i
could tell you right yeah i remember did
you end up did you take the video down
initially i don't remember
no okay i can't remember i was trying to
oh yeah no no no no it was just cause
you said the sponsor comment yes yeah
i've never taken a video down of someone
talking about me
i took a video down once of someone who
screenshotted my tweets without saying
anything because i was like oh i just
don't i deleted the tweets
out there and then people like she takes
down videos of people talking about i've
never in my life done that because i
recognize especially as a content
creator like someone puts effort into
something and puts it out there you have
no right
or you have no rights over that yeah
yeah yeah that's one thing the internet
is very sensitive you can't take down
people's stuff yeah exactly exactly um
so anyways i had just made that comment
on stream where i was like
i can't understand from a business
perspective why you would want your name
on content like that and i said like i
would never work with that company right
but then people spun that into me trying
to take this guy's sponsor from him
right right which i understand
especially because i think the
uh commentary community rightfully so is
like
a little uh like a little bit concerned
about that stuff because her videos get
demonetized easily yeah yeah um
so i i understand
the concern
but i feel like it was a little bit out
of context because the issue was really
just with what he was doing i think if
it happened now if you had had the same
thing had happened now with the same
public sentiment now i don't think it
would it would have turned out that way
it was because that's crazy to me
because like i i think hearing from your
perspective like what's frustrating
about the situation is that i think you
had a very genuine point where you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna dunk on
like pokemane or whatever then just
leave people leave your fa leave her
fans out of it who have like who have
nothing to do with the online internet
lifestyle or anything like that yeah
you're saying like you wouldn't take a
response i'd be like [ __ ] take it off
dude i'd be like [ __ ] them yeah dude
this guy's an [ __ ] yeah yeah and it
seems unfortunate that because you made
that statement afterwards it almost
seemed like it discredited everything
you said before which was like a genuine
point because you know i i i i can't see
what how you know how people can
see it in a way where you it seemed like
you were trying to take this guy sponsor
uh because it was in the heat of the
moment everything like that but that
doesn't really discredit everything that
you said before about the video about it
yeah yeah yeah so i was actually just
like i understand and like i apologize
because i would never want to impact
someone else's livelihood for sure and i
still stand by that like i wouldn't want
to yeah but i also stand by the fact
that i disagree with what he was doing
yeah yeah and i don't think that is okay
well it seemed like at that point it got
to a point where did you even know what
you needed to apologize for because it
seemed
like like like genuinely because it it
seemed like at that time i was just like
i don't even know why people are mad at
pokemane at this point it just seems
like people are looking for anything to
be bad it's just something like domain
like you know
fun things
it's like man i'm bored today what
should we do
dude i'm so glad for the last like two
years with like among us and being more
mainstream and yeah
younger and more female fans like
i feel like uh more of a human being
like i'm treated a little more fairly
because i feel like now there's
a stronger group of people who are
willing to like stand up for my side of
things yeah yeah i'm i'm less so like an
anomaly per se like this this i felt
very objectified during that time in the
sense that um people were speaking of me
as if i wasn't a real person right um
but now i feel like
there are people who like relate to me
enough and obviously i've continued to
make content so yeah yeah you need to
build fans over a long period of time
thanks to oh yeah pardon all thanks to
among us thanks
nothing makes me feel more human than
when i'm playing among us who's my
friends
nothing is done more for women than
among us
like
had nothing else has done
a lot of good yeah
yeah society was never the same when
among us came out
we're all just like back we're all back
in like [ __ ] rome having gladiator
fights
all civilized spaces
like what's done more for feminism than
suffragettes or among us
women actually well personally
because think about it because women
women actually got the right to vote
their voices were finally hurt
every vote mattered
right off the creation of the game we
didn't have to wait a few patches
always from day one day one day one
weekend
oh my god
i do find it so funny like i've talked
to a few streamers now and everyone
talks about this among us period yeah
like it's
it's like it's like a unicorn it's like
everyone's spotted bigfoot like everyone
talks about among us like it was
the golden age of twitch fortnite too
fortnite was the first crazy really and
among us was the second crazy yeah
what's the next crazy gonna be yeah i
don't think not valor i [ __ ] hate
valorance so much there will be one for
a really long time
oh thank you oh you're right yeah
i despise that everyone plays valerian
so much i feel like it's the most boring
game i've ever played in my life
paying fifty dollars for a [ __ ] skin
oh you're scared
it's because i'm bad okay that's why i'm
bad at the game okay if you can't beat
them
also
let's play
i'll make sure you have a great time you
should i i will have like when i'm if i
do when we're back in japan i'll have
like 200 ping and you'll have to it's
fine it's playable i'll just be even
[ __ ]
well then
i wonder why you hate it like
yeah i played on the japanese service
and he still sucks because everyone's
insane on the japanese i would go in the
new rookie lobby and it would be a
ten-year-old boy who's just tried
valentine's the first time
and then he's like oh yeah this is easy
boom just shoots everyone hit the wall
and i'm like no you have to play while
you're here okay okay and you'll have
fun like actually like a five-star it's
hard not to have fun when you can talk
to your friends i think i'm just envious
i i'm like the boy looking outside in
the window with everyone else having fun
and i'm like oh i'm on the japanese side
i can't i i think you were all for
having fun without me actually that
makes a lot of sense that's probably why
that's why i i've actually been the word
valerian from my chat because i don't
want people asking me about playing it
because i'm i'm i have like trauma
because i don't wanna
you need to stream it here enjoy it and
then just let it go you know like that's
just like when i can just if you love it
i'll try i'm willing to try again if i
played with people i'm willing to try
again on 200 ms i'm down to try actually
on america it's like 110 which is
actually way more playable than 200. i
feel like 150 is the cutoff of when it
becomes unplayed really it is i've also
played league on like a hundred pages
but 200 you just you can't
it just sounds like you're like trying
to get him into a new drug it's like
it's not the drug that was bad you just
didn't do it with the right people
i'm really against it
i think all riot games are a drug okay
except for uh
league of runeterra i mean that's just
like legends of room terror
it's like cough syrup
you really need to but
yeah it's like the medicine your mom
forces you to take you know it's like oh
okay here you go there's good lore in it
i swear to god
yeah i maybe i would play it i just [ __ ]
i also just think that there's that
awkward moment when you die in the game
and then you're like i can't wait to
play the next round in five minutes at
least it's not that long
sometimes it's it feels long and then
you buy [ __ ] and you're like i spent all
my money earlier it depends okay you get
killed yeah i am very impatient i am the
[ __ ] who always runs first and then i
die and then i get angry because why am
i impatient it's my fault i suck at this
game that's why you love apex right yeah
she's constantly moving yeah i love it
that makes sense yeah
and also apex is so big in japan as well
and like all the v tubers and all the
japanese streamers [ __ ] love it
that's so cool yeah so it's fun it's fun
but yeah it's kind of died off of them
or i guess like on twitch in general i
feel like there's no meta right now yeah
yeah i was about to ask you like what do
you think the next matter is going to be
on twitch
um
i think it's
in an oddaway irl for a little bit okay
yes and in general like traffic on
twitch
a little bit right i think there's not
going to be like a huge game for a while
there's not going to be another
fortnight or among us yeah maybe for
years or ever again
honestly that the only next thing i can
think of is like
among us
i
no even then it has to be innovative the
reason fortnight was innovative was
because it was the first game to go
mainstream the reason among us was like
innovative in a way first game to go
mainstream i don't think it was the
first there's been games that got
mainstream ever
right there was nothing on the level of
like fortnite when you have celebrities
minecraft sports but it's not it's not
um yeah really or not minecraft is like
not even cod it's like a staple in the
game i guess it's kind of a slow bone as
well i kind of go there fortnight was a
massive trend that went mainstream and
that happened
there's been large games obviously yeah
but it's always within gaming like if
you're not a gamer someone doesn't
really know about it yeah yeah yeah you
just don't know about it right yeah um
but that with like celebrities playing
it's like nfl players yeah drake playing
it it went huge right among us was the
other big boom but it was because of
such a specific set of circumstances
yeah yeah the pandemic on top of it
being one of the first fun games that
had a really large player pool so like a
whole new level of collaboration right
oh yeah
honestly on twitch sometimes it feels
like been there done that with
everything
when is the next time there's gonna be
like something really new and innovative
it's hard to tell i feel like there
might have to be some sort of like tech
innovation
i was i was like really uh against like
the thought of doing irl stuff i thought
this [ __ ] it's weird it's going
outside and then i then i did it once
because um
i did uh i they gave me a backpack uh so
i could do the thing where i'd like take
iron mouse around and i was like okay
actually this is kind of fun yeah like
what if like what if like i did this and
did like saying that where i just got
drunk or something i don't know
and then it was really fun and now i'm
like okay i think they're my favorite
streamers i think though definitely in
the beginning when irl was becoming a
thing it didn't necessarily have like
the best reputation yeah people who were
doing it like a lot of the early people
were doing some really [ __ ] weird
yeah like that like the ice beside in
here
yeah so i think just because of
of that
yeah when you hear the word irl
immediately it's like you think of
people like that it's like oh [ __ ] i
don't want to
get anywhere near that but obviously you
know now it's like you know you have
people like jake and bake and like
people who actually push the boundaries
of ireland in a positive direction yeah
like a fun direction obviously so yeah
the barrier
if i lived in japan oh my god my irl
streams would never end i started doing
more yeah but i always want to do
something interesting i'm just like i
don't want to just [ __ ] walk around
go
to an arcade i've been doing it yeah
yeah the best yeah go to a convenience
store for six hours honestly
stream honestly
i would never do it
you're gonna do you're gonna have such a
fun time because like i forget your [ __ ]
through the roof well the thing is i'm
sorry pokemon my content is higher than
that okay i have higher standards yeah
no no listen him trying to really plan
content this needs to be perfect i don't
plan it i i just twitch viewers i can
love convenience stores i can love them
like that's it i think that's the
difference between being a youtuber and
being a twitch streamer right because
like when i stream i'm like i need to
know what i'm doing this needs to be
planned i need to struggle narrative
yeah
what's the youtube title what is the
youtube title okay honestly the worst
thing for a twitch stream is a narrative
or a story no no no i'm okay i'm against
you there for repeated ones yeah unless
it's like an event or something that you
specifically announced right the reason
youtube and live streaming is so
different and what works best for live
streaming is you want it to be a form of
content that people can tune in at any
point and it's enjoyable i agree that's
why like i think even like a challenge
yeah like when i've i've been offered to
do like cooking streams where it's like
this person against this person i hate
that stuff yeah because someone has to
watch from the beginning middle and end
and that's just not how live streaming
is that's how a video oh man i kind of
disagree in some aspect there i yeah i'm
i'm so in the camp of uh because i only
really started streaming uh like two
years ago uh but it's been going really
well it's been doing well and um my
whole
thought process around it is like make
the live stream obviously as a
interesting as possible but built around
the whole thing so it can fit nicely
it's like a 15 minute youtube video that
is literally how i plan all my streams
and i find that improves personally it
like improved my streams i'm trying to
hit those beats i'm trying to hit those
moments or i guess like um how do you
think that disagrees with my point or
how do you try to make it into a
15-minute video so you mean like intro
outcomes because i agree those things
are good yeah i guess just having a
basic goal to work towards yeah yeah
like there isn't there goals are great
yeah yeah like one general goal because
like
whenever someone does enter the stream
like i think that's kind of in agreement
if anything because whenever someone is
a stream they're like oh you're trying
to make five thousand dollars on gta and
you're this far and it's easy to jump in
and watch i guess i mean like more oh if
it was like completely lost if you don't
have the style exactly like a movie you
can't jump into the middle yeah like it
doesn't feel as well it would have to be
something that can be explained in the
title that's my way of doing it as well
so that's really good because it's also
same with youtube right i gotta hook
them and it has to fit in the thumbnail
and a title so that's kind of the way i
plan most of my things but sometimes
yeah i think that's like
that's third eye opening content
creation no in a good way when you're a
twitch streamer and you think about how
to make a twitch stream a youtube video
before making this like you have a
thumbnail
and then you make the content and then
it's a full stream and then it's a video
like yeah yeah
it's it's it's full circle yeah yeah
cause like
yeah because i've been trying i've been
trying to do that as well recently and
i'm not a twitch streamer at all but
i've like been dabbling in twitch
streams and i notice
the best streams that i do is something
that has that the audience can follow
that has like a specific goal or an end
yeah yeah um i don't think that's good
because it's good for viewer attention
yeah yeah yeah i want to watch this goal
finish yeah yeah exactly yeah as long as
it's an achievable goal i did um i did
like the jump king stuff and i love jump
king i know what i did
i did uh one of the fan maid mods that
like ludwig did and miss gifted that
took them like 40 hours and i was like
i'm better than them i'll i'll do it and
uh yeah it took me like 40 minutes more
than ludwig and i was like i'm never
[ __ ]
it was it was like eight streams
and it was just like
for the viewers by like stream six were
like can you just can you stop can we
just do something else can you [ __ ]
stop please dad you haven't fed us
and it's so sad it's like that is eight
streams that i did to make one youtube
video that's one youtube video but it's
such a [ __ ] good youtube video
because it's like it's like you see the
journey you get like that multiple days
and it's like a whole thing it's good
but you're starving
he's done all the rage games yeah he
went through a phase awesome it was an
addiction well it wasn't a difference
here's my thing and uh obviously because
i i started doing this and i realized
the whole youtube thing and i knew i
noticed that like ludwig was doing it
really well and i was messaging logic
and i'm like hey how do you make your
streams and he told me the same thing
and i was like okay so i kind of like
just i'm like oh my god logics is doing
this but better i'm like i'm just gonna
copy ludwig so i started um i started
doing all the i also wanted to beat him
in things so i started doing the same
thing the same games that he was doing
and i did pogo stock have you played
this game
it's [ __ ] hard jumping is like
nothing compared to this game it is
miserable i can do getting over it i
can't do jumping i love jump kings so
streamer two if i can't finish it within
a two stream you're pissed off okay okay
well jump king you can beat in two shots
hell no i'd be jumping through like
eight hours straight that's impressive
i've played a jump king
how long
like maybe
three hours two or three times that's
nothing that's not i know it's good you
gotta you gotta get in there for the
long haul
i will depression
i i the one challenge right that he did
that i was like i'm not [ __ ] doing
this is i beat pogo stuck the first one
and that's like the easiest of the three
and it took me 30 hours which is less
than all the other ones but i was like
this was such a miserable experience
that i'm like i'm just not doing the
other ones
you could finish a grpg in that time
yeah yeah you can you can mock me louder
you can hold it against me [ __ ] off i'm
not doing it
this is too [ __ ] you're just because
he did it when he was a small streamer
and it didn't matter if he had no
concurrent viewers or something i'm like
why do you see your viewership do this
because they're like oh what's he doing
today i can't wait
not again it's like no so then now i'm
trying to focus more on stuff that can
be done in two or one
yeah i think that's that's the strap
make a stream so that if they if they
miss it they can watch the vod if they
they want to watch the highlight they
can do it but they can just come next to
the next day there'll be something
completely new yeah
um i feel like maybe the next meta will
be something like pokemon go no really
no
irl
something oh
so not pokemon go but maybe something
else so you think irl will play a big
part i think whatever i think so yes
because i don't know like i've done like
one irl stream after like
dissing irl streamers for like the
longest time and i'm like damn it's like
really fun i can see why people do it
yeah yeah yeah
because yeah i mean all all you do is
just do what you normally do
yeah you be human it's a whole new way
of streaming like it's a new experience
for the streamer and a new experience oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i thought for sure the first time i did
it i thought i would immediately hate it
yeah just because again like i had that
like connotation about irl yeah i did it
once and i'm like yeah i'm gonna do it
again but yeah it's good for the like
you do it once or twice two three times
a month i could not do it every day no
you can't do it every day people the
people who do it every day i'm like how
the [ __ ] do you like enjoy life yeah how
would you find enough things to do every
day you don't they don't yeah yeah yeah
sometimes they just live in japan you
probably could well
look at people like rob cd who literally
does an irl stream like every day yeah
and i'm just and jake back in the day
right when he was in japan i'm like how
do you
how do you do it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i like my privacy too
yeah
i like enjoying my food in restaurants
yeah i like having a good time i would
start forgetting like am i streaming or
not yeah yeah just walking around
exactly i get confused yeah i'm like
sometimes i'm like okay i've touched a
bit too much grass recently
i i need to go back here
i need to go back to my [ __ ] cave
become a hermit for a bit like that
yeah it is yeah but like i guess going
to something a bit more positive than
everything we've been talking about
you've just been to korea recently how
was that amazing was that your first
time yeah oh your first time in korea
yeah i've never been mini that i've
never been i've been far away
you should go well we've never been and
yet it's like an hour and a half like
well because getting back into japan is
such a pain that yeah it's like if
you're going to leave it better before
pretending big for me like if it was
even like before the pandemic i was like
oh yeah you can go whenever i want and
then you never go and then i just
haven't been yet you guys should for
sure plan like two weeks to go did you
go for content or for a vacation and
then you're like i can also make content
no i went to stream oh okay okay because
i had such a great time i did this paris
trip a couple years back with jake and
we streamed there it was like that was
so much heck and fun yeah yeah yeah now
that we're past coven will not pass
cover days but at least we can travel
more now yeah i just immediately wanted
to plan something cool and korea was
like the perfect thing i even got to a
point i was there for about 10 days and
i got to a point where i was like i'm
having so much fun should i extend my
trip and then i just kept finding out
about other things to do in korea i'm
like i could extend my trip for three
more weeks just come back
yeah but it is just an a plus of a place
to visit what's your favorite thing to
do though
what is this supposed to be a hot table
yeah i might have sound like an l.a girl
but like the shopping there was crazy
so it was the it was the filtered water
right it was the filtered water yeah
filtered water well they have like the
best skincare stuff in the world yeah
yeah like you go to korea
and you come back looking prettier
the clothes the
fried chicken it's so good yeah no i
mean the plastic surgery
none of that
you still look prettier yeah yeah
i remember me and jake i did a 12 hour
stream one day oh my gosh
did you have a battery that lasts that
long he had more than once oh okay and
he had
like eight hours of that with shopping
and that was some of the highest
viewership we had the whole trip
people like oh you're going to a temple
you're cooking with a professional
korean chef cuckoo cuckoo you're
shopping for 12 hours real [ __ ]
that was the most views well it was like
30 to 35 000
like just
no but the thing is it was growing the
longer we shopped and i was having the
time of my life were you buying anything
or were you just like window shopping
i don't know what i'm doing for my next
video
dude buying [ __ ] on irl streams is so
annoying though because you have the
backpack that's why having a buddy is
great yeah i go pay he's hiding no
credit card leaks no nothing yeah it was
amazing because like you know
i love to shop now i'm like doing my job
while shopping and other people you're
getting paid to shop you're literally
making money as you spend yeah
drugs okay cool but have you ever
shopped while 30 000 people are watching
and that's your job
we're like yo can i get some gifts up
sabotage my shirt
actually the best part of korea was the
fans i've never experienced
such amazing
like
all the fans were amazing and
like the majority of them were girls
awesome
and they always come with a gift
i've never been somewhere where
everybody brought me a gift the whole
time
it was just like yeah it just blew my
mind like this one guy came brought me a
gift
and like everyone's so polite and nice
and sweet yeah yeah and he had me sign
something and i sign it and afterwards
he goes
thanks
he jumped up and down it was the cutest
[ __ ] i've ever seen
like up and down like that it was
adorable did you have to deal with any
uh people being like no you can't film
in here or anything like that
no oh yeah because korea's chill yeah
korea yeah
japan is quite the poor yeah yeah
unfortunately yeah really that's one of
the things i've over the years started
to hate more and more about la and one
of the like things that makes me want to
leave is that people are so
pressed about whether or not you're
filming you have a filming permit never
mind oh really people are like that oh
really you know yeah oh wait in the
morning wait yeah because me and lady
were in round one and the moment we
stepped out of round one to go in the
mall to do our intro yeah because it was
quieter a dude immediately came and was
like no get back in the round one really
yeah but round one was chill so see
japan is like that except they'll say it
to you in the nicest way possible yeah
yeah they'd just be like oh sorry no
camera's here you know you're gonna have
to go out because yeah because i've i've
been on a couple of irl streams with rob
and you know he obviously goes like
malls and [ __ ] like that so he
constantly gets people being like sorry
you can't film any or like sorry you
can't do it it's just a matter of like
okay we'll leave it's odd because if you
say you're streaming
sometimes you're like oh okay then but
then recording is like a big no but
streaming is different
it's yeah because it's just it's
recording with extra steps in japan it's
the weird thing of like you can take
photos but you can't record video yeah
like what's the difference yeah a video
is money yeah
right right luckily the i think the irl
cameras are small so they don't get as
intimidated
if you're carrying around like a dsl oh
bro yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
they get freaked out yeah in korea not a
single place
oh my god i went shopping in one store
and there was another girl live
streaming a girl try on the clothes i
was like
when you say i'm a live streamer that's
what they're going to think fashion
would you ever live in uh korea or any
other country yeah um i think the only
issue for me is again like time zones
yeah i wouldn't know if that would
impact they'd follow you they'd follow
you yeah they'd follow you and you get a
new audience as well right yeah
start building a new audience i think
but it does kind of feel like starting
over yeah
yeah i feel like you've definitely
established yourself enough where if you
did move to a new time zone people would
just be like okay that's just something
to get used to i think it'd be true
this is why i'm saying if it was just
if you make the content around the
videos because okay let's say i got a
stream right like let's say total 200
000 people watch the whole stream
like quadruple that watch the video sure
yeah
no i think that's like yeah the best way
of contemplation legit this episode is
sponsored by harry's listen boys we're
busy we're busy boys busy business oh
and i need a shave that is fast clean
and effective and harry's does it all as
i've mentioned like a billion times on
these ad reasons
i'm addicted to harry say it once again
say it again say it again remind the
audience you know we can't get harry's
in japan every time i go to the uk i
bring back a ton because you can get
them there because it's the cleanest
shape no other razer gives me a shave
like harry's does it's insane how good
of a shave you get for how low the price
is i have never used an another razor
since getting my first harrys well
connor you'll be glad to know because
right now you can get the harry starter
set for just
three dollars three dollars three
dollars and plus you'll get a free
travel size body wash as well slowly oh
my lord the set includes a five blade
razor weighted handle foaming shave gel
and a travel cover a sixteen dollar
value for three dollar reduce just visit
harry's dot com slash trash text it is
actually an insane deal
that's crazy
straight up that's crazy back to the
episode
i just had to start realizing like
doesn't matter if it's like a dead time
in the stream because it's all getting
[ __ ] cut anyway yeah video's good
yeah because you it just completely
shifts your mindset because sometimes
you have a stream that's not doing well
like viewer-wise but you know at least
the video yeah but you know that's the
thing about that it's going to be a bang
of video and you're going to like make
that money back yeah because i had like
uh i had some of the most viewership
i've ever had playing alden ring and
yeah which is i think the opposite for
like most people
and i i was shocked i was like wow and
but the video said terribly like no one
gave a [ __ ] because this i don't know if
there's just so many album ring
better
videos
really strange yeah so if just because
it's doing well live doesn't mean it's
going to lend itself well to too well
for a video and also just because it's
doing well or not well for a certain
stream it doesn't mean it's not going to
do well for you right like oh yeah i've
had like i've played a bunch of like
story based games on my streams where
i'm just like no that that doesn't get
viewership
but like yeah yeah like i remember like
my pokemon rc streams at one point were
doing like better than a lot of other
streams i was doing right like seven
eight streams into it and i'm just like
oh cool i thought i thought this was
going to suck
but yeah it was awesome and then and
then i try and do something else that is
like big for other people and it doesn't
quite do as well for me right so it's
like i've just noticed now not just the
content creator but sometimes the
audience like of course garnered i
prefer certain things yeah absolutely so
that was at that point i was just like
yeah i'm just going to [ __ ] do
whatever i wanted so some people will
just
lend well to certain games and certain
activities and other personalities just
don't yeah
absolutely would you ever want to stream
in japan
i already have
and i will again
you're gonna come back for six [ __ ]
hours yeah i wanna see if you can do an
irl stream at a conbini japan i wanna
see how well that will do i bet it's
gonna do really well honestly honestly
i think it'll do frustratingly well yeah
do numbers what i want to do in japan
again is just
go to an arcade and play a claw game for
six hours that was like some of the most
fun i had i don't even know why yeah
like you're playing a game but irl but
you can do that but you could do that
here
um no but it's not as exotic if it's not
in japan you know even though it's the
same company it's round one the same
arcades playing the same games you put
japan in the title views are gonna watch
right not just that but also um
going to round one would be difficult i
can't i don't stream anywhere in l.a
like i will not do it right unless i can
book out the whole place oh yeah yeah
we're just getting a stream as well
right right a thousand times safer in
korea and japan than i do here yeah
which is sad that's like that's a huge
irl streaming like limitation i i don't
feel safe just walking around with a
backpack alone or even with someone
yeah that's just that goes beyond
streaming though right yeah that's just
in general i think
yeah even just visiting here i'm
immediately like i don't feel safe in a
lot of places yeah we did uh did the
round one stream and that was uh that
was it was okay it was it was the first
hour was fine but then obviously when
people start figuring out where you are
and then it started ramping up because
we weren't we weren't moving around we
were just in round one
it was fine people really nice though i
think round one attracts a good crowd
though luckily sure but then we're also
guys i love going to round one offline
yeah yeah wait a second oh my god the
manager recognized me once
she like she started crying i was like
yeah we were around one the other day
and one of the employees there was like
oh you can just just come come up and
i'll just get you a ticket yeah yeah i
was just like oh okay cool i felt really
bad because there's like a bunch of
people lining up i'm like no no i'm
waiting in line you got a free ticket
yeah [ __ ] i paid for mine
i wish i wish he
fixed that stupid mega stacker machine
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] oh it's a machine
where the blocks you know they go across
and you gotta yeah they skip it they
they give it i i yeah absolutely skip it
yeah i've played that one yeah yeah yeah
you know the one because
i'm a gamer so like no i can get to the
last one no problem i'm not a [ __ ]
idiot and then it you press it and it
[ __ ] goes
intentionally yeah
it has to be on like a lottery system
i went on a date with a guy once we went
around one it was so hecking fun because
he's like more of a normie and i'm just
like gaming my ass off
and he has a little like card with the
money and he's like and i'm like and
he's like
again okay
and i was stuck on that one for so long
and i knew
no i knew i was doing it right it's a
con dude i was getting so pressed and
he's like again okay
yeah
[Music]
this game is blind i swear to god i am
doing a frame perfect input no legit
like
the summoning salt video was in the
making dude yeah
it was
it was yeah i i think we i spent like an
hour on ski ball trying to get uh eight
you know the 10 000 in the corner like
the hardest one to get i was like i'm
gonna get eight out of nine to get the
bonus and i could only get seven that's
like a machine though you were there for
like an hour and a half just trying to
do this
i had dudes come up to me who were like
dude you're [ __ ] sick at this [ __ ]
and like
they spammed me and i'm like i'm i do
not care i want these tickets leave me
the [ __ ] alone it was it was like it was
like seeing connor
yeah right it was like seeing kind of
playing irl jump king because it was
just like the same movement over and
over before i swear i was trying to
perfect the body movement of throwing it
in the exact same spot because i
remember at one point
like it's all in the hips yeah it's only
him because i remember at one point in
the night i was like i saw you from
across the room like playing ski ball
and i'm like okay he's playing skill
ball i'll just go to the rhythm machine
games a couple of times yeah i feel i
was there for like an hour i came back
and he's like still there but like 10
times sweatier yeah yeah i was really
getting into it because i was getting my
goal was to get as many high scores as
the thing as possible i'd got like the
high score like my second try on this
bean bag tossing [ __ ] and i was like
dude i'm actually nuts i just got to get
the high score and everything yeah and
uh yeah that broke me there was also
another thing that like there was like
this [ __ ] milk tossing thing and it
was driving me insane and i was getting
angry that i couldn't get the high
school yeah it was like a milk jug i
need to throw a ball into it but it was
the the thing was designed so the ball
wouldn't bounce in nicely yeah and it
was i was like is it me so where am i am
i bad am i not getting a jug [ __ ]
yeah i was like freaking out it was
round one you know i can get over a jug
being [ __ ] or me not perfecting my
skee ball but yeah that when it when
they actually
that's why i get addicted to games where
i know it's not a scam and i'm just bad
because i'm like i like i know i'm the
i'm the problem but when they con me i'm
like vehemently against it i'm like
absolutely [ __ ] not i hate you i hate
you so much
see that's why i was like glad i was a
casual gamer because we all started with
the same amount of credits i think me
and joey just spent like an hour or two
in the rhythm game section you're just
having a [ __ ] great time and then we
come over to connor and he's like almost
ran out of credit yeah we're like dude
we got like 500 credits left souls just
like yeah yeah that's why i like rhythm
games though because you
you get the experience you pay it's
value for money you get value for money
right skeeball was only like 25 cents
apart yeah but you you ran through that
in like 10 seconds your happiness at the
end they're happy yeah yeah yeah i
walked away with a minecraft glow-up
light i'm i'm probably i'm aware
more money than us that's what i'm
looking for shut the [ __ ] up
we literally put the same amount of
money in the cards i'm sorry i spent my
money faster than you yeah yeah i i we
literally spent like half the amount
that you spent because like i i'd like i
remember like
oh we're all rich it's fine and it's a
competition for you everything's a
conversation
don't lie to me
a competition
no because like i remember we were just
playing like the rhythm games i'm like
damn you get three songs for one credit
yeah holy [ __ ] it's like a good ten
minutes at least one credit and here's
connor going
like it's only three credits guys it's
like i didn't know you could speed run
skeeball
the one thing i will say that i think
round one america does better than round
one or anything
is the card
oh yeah none of the arcades in japan
even though they have cards that keep
your progression no one has decided on a
system that allows you to just load up
money on a card because like so simple
yeah and i it only works for some
machines and so there's you can play
with like circa which is like a tapping
thing but the thing is [ __ ] like to
pick the thing you want to play with
pick the money you have to pay with then
have to hold it and it doesn't work as
well yeah yeah cause i do these videos
where i do like the crane game uh
playing against each other and i have to
carry around just a sack of money to
just put in it it's fine that's kind of
funny for the video yeah yeah but it's
i've spilled it before and it's really
awkward so i'm like
[Music]
yeah it's nice but when you're spamming
a game yeah yeah
yeah they have iron gatcha as well like
they have like uh you put like a ten
bucks in and then you get like a bowl
and then you might you can win like oh
yeah that was fun as [ __ ] yeah i do like
doing those but uh i've never won
anything good only uh pokemon arceus but
i already had a copy of it so
it's just sitting in my room
it was kind of high yeah it's kind of
nice no it was a waste of money round
one is so fun
it's good it is yeah i want america's
really good i thought it was dog [ __ ] i
was kind of surprised too when i went to
the one year here because because i've
been to some pretty [ __ ] sad arcades
in the u.s yeah yeah i went to a dave
and buster's david buster's is that
stuff
you think arcades are bad like they can
be bad here in the uk they are pathetic
oh my god there is nothing in the uk
well in australia as well this year yeah
when i went to round one like i i i had
such a great time i thought about all
the people that only know of david
you know is steven buster's bad yeah
prior to this time most
mid arcade you could possibly think of
same thing you say submit arcade
compared to the arcades in the uk that's
still like a 10 out of 10 arcades if the
machines work it's better than the one
in the uk yeah yeah yeah yeah half of
them they never work the buttons are
like i remember they had like uh this is
one really popular arcade in london just
half the machine just don't work
yeah time crisis you can you can put the
money in but the gun just doesn't
[ __ ] track yeah but you've already
put your money in so yeah
and like
if you get a machine that's like it's
it's impossible to get a machine that's
like below functional yeah fully
functional below like 10 years old
because all the games like old as hell
like here you actually get like proper
rhythm games proper arcade games proper
claw machines and you get this [ __ ]
nothing yeah i was surprised how
up-to-date the round one was where we
went to especially like the rhythm games
i was like oh this is nothing like yeah
live from japan this is nothing like the
dave and busters that i went to that one
time yeah
dude there's this like mech game that
you can play in japanese arcades that's
so [ __ ] sick we get to pilot a mech
and it's got hydraulics and it [ __ ]
moves around it's so fun and it's a
battle royale as well yeah so so you're
literally battling against pilots yeah
other mech pilots online and you are
literally piloting a map there's that
many
mechs oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
even in the one arcade the one we went
to where we discovered that game there
was like i think eight machines yeah
yeah just like that fully like hydraulic
machines that you have to put where
seatbelt yeah cause oh my god or it
won't stop
one of the most recent like uh
rumors i don't know what you call them
that was spread about me was that i do
cocaine on stream i don't know if you
guys saw that that's [ __ ] tight dude
that's [ __ ] tight let's do it do you
[ __ ] let's rip
why because when i was
18 or 19
wait you guys know the japan crate thing
yeah yeah i had those and there was like
a candy that was like white powder you
know and i like lined it up and i made
this joke
a joke when i was 19. right and people
found that clip and they're like oh my
gosh she says cocaine on stream wow
so you think substance abuse is funny
yeah it's a joke about wow
wow i can't [ __ ] believe
okay was that the most ridiculous rumor
that's been spread around you i think
that's like the most recent right
yeah probably one of the most ridiculous
yeah especially for someone who like i
don't really drink i don't do drugs yeah
i'm kind of boring low-key
and they're like you do cocaine on
stream like imagine
let's just break a federal law on stream
and uh
she's just trying to hype herself off
it's right yeah yeah have you have you
had any other like ridiculous rumors
that you've that's just like popped up
i'm sure you're you've had your fair
share yeah yeah yeah sometimes hard to
think of until they just come up like
this is a crack
speaking of crack you know that was one
of the most bizarre controversies i
think you got in was the the band word
list
oh my god i mean people got mad about
all sorts of things like she has these
banned words and i'm like yeah because
weirdos online abuse
what is annoying what is this
controversy i am
so yeah i think someone leaked some of
your banned words right were they
yeah yeah maybe maybe i genuine like
yeah i remember p people being upset
that i banned words in my chat mm-hmm
well like of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because like it was a thing at the
point with like all the leafy videos in
his oh yeah yeah it's totally
like half of my unbanned forms or unban
requests nowadays are like oh i was a
cringy leafy fanboy sorry about that
i've grown and learned
literally
everyone loves that um
yeah so
i think people at some point were mad
that i had a bunch of bandwards yeah for
what i don't know actually one weird
controversy i do want to like hear your
opinion about is uh the v tubing
controversy oh yeah like what the [ __ ]
happened there okay so for anyone that
might not know uh like
the beginning of the pandemic-ish at
some point
i thought youtubers were so cool yeah
and i i love me some good anime girl art
right so i got um like a v tubing model
done and i was like oh this could be a
fun thing to use if i don't feel like
being on camera right yeah and then when
i came out with it all like i think a
lot of people were really mad yeah yeah
yeah like i saw that people were mad but
at the same time i was like
why yeah where was like in that
controversy oh that's
yeah where was the majority of like the
the backlash coming from there like what
was it yours who was who was mad no for
sure not my audience if anything they
were intrigued and
funnily enough in hindsight i'm like i
hope i was a positive force in like
youtubers becoming more popular yeah
because
i think a lot of my audience is probably
very different from the v tubing
audience but i helped probably like
normalize the idea of like using this
sort of tech right um
obviously youtubers are popping because
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so cool but i think people were just mad
because
i think a lot of people are used to
being mad at me if that makes sense
right yeah yeah that's that's that's how
i felt yeah
um and then i think some other ones it
was probably like a little bit of a
gatekeeping thing partially
understandable where they're like we
don't want you to like ruin this sacred
community
which obviously feels bad for me because
i'm like i obviously i'm not looking to
ruin anything like this is a cool piece
of tech that i want to showcase tomorrow
it's a dumb argument when you look at
the fact that many corporate entities
have youtuber models yeah so i i mean
come on you can't blame a person who's a
creator for doing it when
there's [ __ ] i don't know and i think
an airline has one and it's like for
what purpose i mean nowadays [ __ ]
every japanese yeah
they have one as well
everyone has it yeah why are you my
friends made them as well like they're
just fun
were you expecting any controversy when
you
launched your youtuber model um
or was it just like ah here we go again
they found something else
i think it was an in-between where i was
just like so used to it i was like
people are gonna be mad at me
but i think it was an instance where i
wasn't that upset because i was actually
reassured by a lot of like really really
nice and cool v tubers i think iron mice
our mouse might have been one of them
memories yeah um and they were like no
like this is cool why not she's like
bringing more eyes to the community yeah
yeah and she's like being nice and
respectful and she commissioned someone
from the community like if anything it's
like bringing more words yeah
oh my god i remember at that time
everybody was booked up for months like
oh
yeah well i think the issue yeah a good
time i hope for the community yeah
because i think the issue at that time
was that v tubing was still like this
underground thing hadn't like broken
into like the especially in the west
especially in the west you know in japan
totally different culture but in the
west it was still like this underground
thing that was kind of getting traction
and it kind of felt like i'm sure to a
lot of fans being like you know when
your underground indie band comes out to
get signed up by like a big company
you're like damn they've look at all
these normies coming the joints
oh yeah i love that man i heard them in
the marvel movie yeah yeah yeah
there's so much more than that
yeah um and i think there's been a
similar sentiment for a lot of people
with twitch
they're like oh twitch becoming more
mainstream and normie and minecraft kids
but
i personally obviously kind of biased i
feel like it's better for the platform
overall to be more inclusive and you can
still have your pockets whatever the
heck you want yeah yeah um i missed the
time when it was called justin.tv yeah
yeah i remember those times yeah good
old days i mean i understand the
sentiment but i also think there isn't
really any one person or force anyone
should be mad at when things get more
popular that's just like the life cycle
of a product right if it's a good
product just blame society that's that's
we live in this world we live in a
society in a society
i gotta ask okay there's there's one
thing i do want to hear why you did it
okay watching avatar on stream
okay we're bringing out the hard
questions now we're bringing out the
hard questions so this isn't god's first
rodeo
you know
you did it previously right on offline
tv yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
as well yeah yeah yeah well i watched
avatar on stream because well it's just
a really really great show
metas are
very very common right okay
there is a among us meadow fortnight
meta and meta just means like what is
most popular what is really bringing
viewership et cetera et cetera right if
you want to be a streamer that has a
very very long lifespan and career you
must change with the times at least to
some degree
twitch had gotten to a point where they
weren't personally um like banning
people for playing copyrighted content
yeah they
they were essentially like a safe haven
for that kind of thing and they forced
the copyright holder to take down that
content themselves right
and so what happened was you had major
very very large streamers like toast as
you said xqc like everybody just started
watching flat out tv shows and movies
and whatever yeah he watched um
death note yeah yeah i think he watched
naruto as well definitely next you see
all was watching hunter hunter hunter
yeah yeah so you had these people
watching all these shows and
miss kiff also watched the avatar on
stream yeah so obviously to me i'm like
oh these people
watched things let me watch
the same thing that someone has already
streamed right to a similar sized
audience as me yeah
but i got hit with the deal
and then the pirating messages
what i want to know was like did you all
did you all know that you were just like
okay we're going to wait for the first
person to get here and then we're going
to stop afterwards okay
right it was basically like oh this is a
normalized thing
right at this point
um so even like yeah it was just a
tricky thing
if we watched anime in japan we'd go to
jail yeah we're doing it on stream
because because fair use is not a law
yeah i'm abusing copyright is like they
they really go after it there yeah uh
but i i think for us it was kind of like
what the [ __ ] is happening because
because you know a lot of the time we
worked with japanese corporations and we
were trying to build up that bridge of
like no youtubers and twitch they're not
scary come on just like work with us and
then it was like please don't look at
what is happening please please stay on
youtube it's like these ain't our mans
they say no man they are not like us
because it was like oh my god this good
will that we're trying to bring another
because their show like these companies
are so scared i think i worked with
crunchyroll on something and they are
like very
i mean it's not even themselves it comes
to handling
yeah yeah yeah because it's not very
very strict them half the time that that
like why they're scared it's like
because they have the japanese people
breathing down their neck just being
like you if you [ __ ] up we are gonna
pull the show yeah yeah yeah
yeah which is again very understandable
and honestly i felt really bad about
that because like
it was the apology video yeah that's
what you should have made an apology
video about and then i would have
watched it on stream and [ __ ] laughed
at you
abusing copywriting no jokes why did you
make an apology video so we could have
clicked basically
my luck like someone who is yeah well
scrutinized to no end yeah
but this was the one instance that
wasn't it's like you have
so many other even larger streamers than
me doing this thing and as soon as i do
it i'm the one who i i i was honestly i
was really appalled mainly with uh
twitch i couldn't believe that they left
how inconsistent yeah yeah how long it
is
they just say copyright holder if you
find it then it's on you to tell us and
then we'll take it down it just yeah it
just felt like it was like because and
we were all on youtube before the
adpocalypse yeah we were just like it
was just like vietnam flashbacks like oh
no oh here it goes
oh no here we go
oh [ __ ] people on twitch were worried
about that too luckily that's not what
ended up happening yeah um i i feel like
something's gonna happen do you think
there's an inevitably inevitability that
something like that is going to happen
on twitch
because i don't think anyone expected it
to happen on youtube until it happened
no everyone's really cool
it's well established enough that it
likely won't however i do think we're
heading into a recession i mean we're
tech reception
world right now i think you know sorry i
was gonna say i think because of that we
might see similar things of like
not as many sponsorships not as many
crazy ad rates yeah yeah so it might
almost feel like an adpocalypse but it
won't have anything to do with the
platform right the entire world is going
through an ad apocalypse right now
it's like yo what are we getting like
inflation you're like
did that crazy i do think i mean am i
doing who feels like content creators
have been a little bit um
overvalued for like a year or two
like some things are just like maybe
you're at the top though you're at the
top so you get the premium stuff yeah
yeah yeah we're little bottom feeders
guys they're in a million billion
dollars like a million billion a million
billion dollar man
talking about
that that's that's our patrons man we
thank you very much patrons by the way
yeah we have to fight tooth and nails
for like any company's like to take us
seriously
especially in japan though
yeah yeah you think we're you know we're
doing pretty good yeah
you need to hit up people in america
yeah that's why like i felt here in l.a
everyone's just like yes yes king say
what you want yes you what's you know
like what do you want to say what do you
want to do how do you want to work
together yeah like in japan it's just
like why are you here at my door like
who is why are you on your knees begging
yeah who is this random sassy child
that's just appeared right i'm sorry do
you speak japanese i didn't think so
yeah exactly right exactly exactly yeah
it's it's been a totally different it's
it's almost been like a culture shock
yeah just seeing how the infrastructure
is totally different than kombini's
though [ __ ] those conveniences
the kombini's the the convenience store
convenience store sorry [ __ ] that's
awesome sorry japanese i wouldn't
understand yeah yeah
i really don't that's just so much
cooler
you can you can watch this podcast on
stream if you want by the way that's
and then we'll make a special video
where we just go around copy striking
yeah all of your streams
well as as long as we can react to you
reacting to this then then it's all good
when i did a
sabbath on and i went to bed i just
played episode of trash taste that's all
i did oh that's really nice because i
was like i can't believe i can't believe
you've been breaking out copyright it's
two and a half hours of content yeah and
i can there's so [ __ ] much money
why would you watch avatar when you
could just watch all of trash taste
right there's way more
the trash tastes better that's gonna be
the next matter
everyone should stop watching masterchef
yeah there was a gordon ramsay yeah
there was that was the one watching tv
shows and movies almost got like
normalized and they're like effort anime
yeah yeah i wonder who is the first one
to be like you know what [ __ ] it let's
just watch [ __ ] whole tv shows let's
just do it i forget i was it was uh xqc
wasn't i watching master jeff i thought
i thought it started with like him
watching masterchef no i think a lot of
other people watched masterchef before
he did right but i don't know who like
took it that step further and did
animate mind you can i just say like
it was you know ecstasy toast
me we all did a lot of people did it and
so many other streamers were like okay
it's time to watch it now which doesn't
make it okay
but just to say like i think a lot of
people
assume if something isn't being punished
yeah and it's like it seems permissible
right even if it's not okay what do you
think about react content in general
um
it's not that deep
id right okay i think
there's kind of a middle ground
obviously
what is your question specifically
i think it's like it's interesting
talking about talking with streamers
again coming from youtube initially
because
uh i don't know if you followed youtube
history but there was this like whole
movement for like two years where it was
like react content is the plague it's
disgusting yeah and it was this whole
thing of like so when i came to twitch i
was like oh
everyone loves it here
and it's kind of crazy seeing like the
the 180 right
um and yeah
it's conflicting they only love it now
again back when all those videos and all
that stuff yeah people were like she
just reacted
and that makes her spawn at the devil
and now it's like so normalized yeah
because everyone's doing it yeah and
it's crazy to look back and be like
people were mad at me for so many things
that nobody cares about now
what's that about yeah it's just the
longer i've been on the internet the
longer you realize man people just have
really short memories yeah like
cycles right yeah yeah yeah people get
angry really easily but unless you have
done something like you know [ __ ]
little children or whatever yeah we're
just gonna [ __ ] forget about it most
of the times people forget about that
sometimes
most of the time it's just it's just
cancellation of the week basically yeah
it's like oh who's the translation of
the week yeah it's like monster of the
week he's just like oh who is it this
week all right i think react content is
hard to talk about because there's
there's like such a spectrum of it like
yeah are you really adding to the
content like it's a ton there's an
unfair question to me to ask it was it
was loaded it was late no
i guess that's my answer like if you're
adding to the content a ton i think
there's a very fair
like i think you can have a discussion
about whether or not that's fair use and
i think you have a good argument for ap
well i think i think youtube definitely
had that period where it's like uh
insert profession here reacts to
something along the way oh it's still
professional it's like that i think
that's that's good content yeah are you
really eating
oh we go we go for a long time with
trash too yeah that's fine that's fine
i'm sorry yeah yeah that's mine yeah no
no no
you're already doing it
i'll only have three pieces
running questions
speed fire all right top three anime
yeah it was i was gonna we got to talk
about it
you know it's like core memory growing
up and watching that and just falling in
love with that one i love when he he
lets miggy take over his heart and he
just becomes a [ __ ] chad and then he
just when you see the before the
immediate his hair goes spikes up he
[ __ ] he has sex right away and it's
like this is the greatest show ever
um again character yeah okay what else
um
i'm really bad with this kind of thing
because i don't usually rank things like
if you say your favorite movie your
favorite tv show
it's just it's easy to ask i know yeah
is there any like personal favorites
that you just want to shout out just
reword the questions yeah yeah yeah
because i mean it matters to me because
like when someone says yeah okay what's
your top three okay just tell us your
favorites yeah i like all the normal
ones i i
definitely i mean like shonen jump like
demon slayer jiu-jitsu
i really know i really wanted to say
like a hentai as a joke but i couldn't
think of one
you know the normal anime is like
cow girls
um
obviously i love death note growing up i
probably watched that like twice yeah i
watched that on toasted stream
[Music]
why would you not spend that lifetime
watching one piece do you like a
character development you should watch a
show called backy
oh yeah you should watch parky that's
one we advocate for yeah
it's like the ugliest [ __ ] thing it's
like these extremely muscular dudes just
fighting each other and it's but there's
growth there's growth there
i've been enjoying spike's family
obviously of course i also enjoy food
yes right yeah
you do too soon like demonstr everybody
likes those growing up i
like fell in love with attack on titan i
was like 14 yeah morocco in africa
downtown all the episodes i forget how i
have no interest i know
so now 27 i'm so mad
because like if you had just fed me
properly throughout the years i'd still
be happy today but i feel like attack on
titan did not do that have you ever
been out with it
no that's why i'm like you lost me
throughout the years but i loved you so
much
one more final season
well so so there's there's a 2013 right
so nine years yeah 2013.
yeah it came out twenty thousand
yeah that probably lines up yeah i think
i think it came out like the original
attack attack on titan came out 2013 13.
yeah so it's been it's been nine years
my favorite thing about anime and you
could probably understand with parasite
a little bit
an attack on titan is just when it looks
so
[ __ ] up
in a way that would never exist in
humanity like these massive titans with
these
jumps yeah borderline disgusting smiles
like
i guess the closest word to it would be
gore but it doesn't have to be bloody
it's just
freaky yeah um and just how much i guess
how much more possibility there is
within anime i mean i guess cgi is
really advanced now but it just like
that's why every live-action anime fails
because you take the animated aesthetic
and you put it to live action it never
works out yeah
it never works out so yeah that's why i
initially like i loved attack on titan
so much and i think just because
i didn't keep up with it throughout the
years yeah
but not gonna finish it and maybe i'll
start now's the perfect time because you
could just marathon it now we had to
wait like [ __ ] like i can't remember
how many years we had to wait for season
two and i think it was like three or
four years
exactly yeah that's why i will happily
marathon i think i watched season two
like foster
we're on season four now no we're on
we're on a season we just finished
season three no the final season part
two yeah yeah and then it was the final
season part one but it isn't the final
season because there is another final
season that's coming out which is the
final season the final final scene
before this oh season three part one and
then there was season three part two
yeah and now we're on the final season
yeah but then
i still think there's going to be a
movie i don't know
i am betting my money wait because you
like the whole this is just the hobbit
all over season three is like the most
hype season yeah season three is [ __ ]
insane you will lose your [ __ ] that's
after the basement
no no no wait you don't you know what's
in the basement i want or like i
remember talking about it with some
friends so i wanna say maybe
no you know if you've seen the hype
[ __ ]
it's burned into my memory yeah okay so
you guys don't care about spoilers and
stuff
spoiler alert spoiler warning for attack
on titles oh yeah okay
so
because i watch certain parts of it
throughout the years it's almost hard to
remember i remember i watched the
initial setup the first season yeah yeah
and then a little bit more of them kind
of fighting then you find out oh my god
this person is a titan too yeah
this person is a titan yeah oh my god
this oh my god that right yeah and then
something about the basement and then
the storyline just lost me and i okay so
you didn't get to the base yeah yeah
yeah guaranteed like the basement
to it yeah yeah yeah because they didn't
they probably talked about it a little
bit initially but i don't think you
actually got to the basement they don't
get into it until some later it's like
season three right they don't yeah no
season yeah yeah yeah because those
finals
they don't get to the basement until
literally the last two episodes of
season three where they explain
everything and it's worth it it's one of
the few it's one of the few shows i'm
thinking about
it's one of the few shows that builds up
this massive event and then delivers
yeah wow
i think i was like getting annoying
waiting
yeah there is there is a lot of
backstory so the basement because they
have to because season two is like
it's kind of really slow and then season
three initially is it not about titans
yeah so it's really it gets very like
political you're like what the [ __ ] but
then it all makes sense you're like ah
this is amazing yeah yeah everything
it's worth it so yeah
[Music]
it is worth the hype yeah it is it is
the mainstream anime that i think is
just genuinely worth all this like all
the reputation that it has yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah so sometimes i feel kind of bad
talking about anime because
i feel like
people are like you watch anime casually
fake faces
it's like there's a lot of emotions in
there yeah yeah but for me legit it's
like i've been watching since i was
young it's just like i'll just watch
yeah that's fine um like promise
neverland was great oh that's all season
well season one season one we don't
don't we don't talk about season two
yeah
yeah so um there's this one that i can't
remember it's it's new it's on netflix
it's about this little boy who lives
alone
oh
that one oh oh
okay so
cute why you watched that i watched like
a few episodes oh wow see that's how you
know casual viewers yeah yeah you're on
netflix and you're like i'll just watch
the first thing that comes together but
it's good it's just so cute
i'm not gonna be like you should really
watch it because the storyline the
character but it's just like you watch
whatever that's just like slice of life
anime in general yeah yeah yeah it's
hard enough finding anime that you enjoy
watching so if you can get enjoyment out
of a show who the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] yeah
who gets critically acclaimed
like i uh also watch sword art online
probably like all the really popular
ones yeah i tried to watch re zero and i
couldn't i need do you guys think all
right zero three zero one zero zero yeah
uh r easier
you don't like three zeros for me it's
like um like when you're replying to an
email
re that one thing you said earlier
yeah i like when you [ __ ] said that
dude it's like reply zero yeah that's
why zero
reply zero
yeah you didn't like three zero one let
me
explain i watched like the first um
like two or three episodes and for some
reason
i could not watch someone do the same
thing over and over again just to like
get it right like
that was tilting me but i heard it's
great so i'm not gonna say it's bad yeah
they actually stopped doing that kind of
they don't do it as much yeah actually
the first three episodes i'd say are
probably like maybe some of the weakest
parts of the show this season that's
probably why i didn't finish it yeah i
mean like i'm a three episode
[Music]
ram i'm i'm so normal i love her it's so
it's it's like liking vanilla you know
whenever you go to crane games in japan
there's always ram figures yeah
she's like the most popular girl i still
see her everywhere that's why i'm like i
don't i do not hate the anime by the way
i just did not finish it like i knew his
business
when i saw rem in round one here on the
crane game like damn rem's gone
international now yeah yeah she's always
been i'm pretty sure that's true that's
true if you could pick one anime that
you could watch on stream no worry about
you
that's a copyright yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a great
question that's a really great question
loki i might go back and say avatar
oh
i mean is avatar not just like a great
i haven't watched that avatar before
i
only recently watched avatar because i
didn't grow up with nickelodeon yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome isn't it it's
absolutely i can totally see why the
comparison of this is an anime and this
is not an anime please because it you
know technically speaking it's not an
anime but like it certainly gives the
feeling of like a really [ __ ] good
shonen yeah yeah it does
um but if you're asking me like to
stream yeah i gotta think like a content
creator oh oh okay
yeah one piece i was about to say if i
could choose it would be one piece
because it's literally endless hours of
content
or something yeah
[Music]
and there's like insane fight scenes i
think it's a little
i think it would probably drive more
viewership than like uh
avatar is a little bit slower at times
for your whole summer about this story
which again storyline with streams yeah
you know as much as i i i'm like i don't
think reaction videos are the best stuff
you know you sometimes you want to watch
people's reactions to like the fights
the people who react way too hard to
things on youtube
oh my god they start [ __ ] freaking
out and there's like nothing
that's why that's why etiquette was such
a thing right yeah like everything he
reacted to was either wholesome or just
like he was so funny yeah like he was
more of the entertainment than the thing
he wanted yeah exactly exactly that's
why it's hard to say reaction content
bad or reaction content good like yeah
there's a lot of it it's a spectrum see
i'm an awful reactor like
like i remember like yeah
i just like have commentary on my mind
and sometimes it's just like she's like
the lioness the lioness retirement face
yeah yeah yeah
i don't react to [ __ ] while i watch it i
react to it like afterwards
[Music]
can you just pause yeah yeah just every
10 seconds actually um
i think that's part of the streamer
lifestyle you know yeah but also when
people ask me about react content i'm
not here to be like this is my opinion
and what is right
the way what i think is like i cannot
wait for surely the day whether it's in
2 5 10 20 years when co-watching things
sort of kind of starting to try and do
it but it's not that still too much like
copyright and limitations if that was um
if that was like allowed that would be
the next meta 100
because being able to like
watch something with someone who's
watching it yeah with the reactions of
tens of thousands of people at once like
there's just a there's no it's an
unparalleled
i would if i experience i'd love to yeah
i mean we've been trying to convince
japanese companies for like yeah only
one yeah yeah you're not the only one
one day one day one final question what
is this um you know your profile picture
on twitch what's with this green circle
thing that everyone's doing oh okay so
basically i mean you know when you're on
twitch you see all the people that are
live the green circle is just something
that makes someone stand out
do you think it actually improves
viewership or through click-through rate
or anything like that
have you seen this yeah yeah definitely
and i've always wondered i was like oh
is this like a perk of like the top
story i thought it was like i thought it
was like an instagram thing where it's
like close friends
well but they i think they added
something like that too like twitch
stories no but there's like a circle
around when it says live that's on
youtube right
no there's something on twitch as well
really yeah i don't remember exactly off
the top of my head they added a circle
themselves too yeah but the one that
people just draw on and put off
to me i mean you know i can't give you
direct analytics yeah but i feel like
i i i just wanted to know i just wanted
to yeah but at what point does it turn
into like a [ __ ] red arrow like you
know
you
i feel like it's one of those things
that's like it's just a step i'm going
to try it yeah yeah well i think my
background is green so
yeah i don't think it would work for you
because i didn't swap the color of mine
yeah because i remember i was talking to
toast and he was like yeah streamers
just copy each other yeah like one
person can be like yeah this content
creators do yeah they do they do but
like he was saying like yeah streamers
copy each other even if there's like no
basis around it it just like feels right
like what's your source trust me bro
yeah yeah yeah
i made it the [ __ ] out
but there's this interesting phenomenon
on twitch which i don't really love but
essentially like when something becomes
the norm if you're not keeping up you're
the weirdo yeah yeah right right it's
like you really you have to be tough
all the time yeah which is tiring
but i guess it keeps it a little how you
stay on the top man pokemon number one
man if you see all the top streamers or
watching movies on their stream yeah
like well if i don't do it yeah i mean
you know if you miss out on one trend or
meta here and there it's not a big deal
but if you're continuously avoiding
these opportunities where like clearly
the majority of the traction and
exposure
is going to yeah it's not it's gonna be
it's gonna be detrimental yeah yeah
it'll be detrimental to your career
obviously yeah
damn well thank you for giving us all
your insights yeah yeah tips and tricks
yeah look at all these patrons though do
you see that flying across the screen
let's support the show
[Music]
they're just going everywhere
but uh hey if you want to support the
show go over to our patreon patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify and uh
yeah go check out pogies do you have
anything you want to shout out
anything um
um
i guess that's a no
world peace and love
and co-way water very good filtered
water
no no no it's really really good well
thank you for watching thank you very
much
nice to other human beings even through
screen oh yeah also these guys are
freaking great like i have felt very
comfy and happy since yeah since meeting
you guys doing this podcast
thanks for watching guys and we'll see
in the next one
[Music]
you